Film Courage: How do you become a professional
director if no one will give you a chance?
Jason Satterlund, Filmmaker: Ah, that's
such a good question and I think that's
the question that everyone asks every
day, how how in the world do you do it
you know I just two nights ago I was just
having dinner with two filmmaking friends
one was a producer director the other was a
director we asked ourselves the exact same
question the maddening question of how in
the world do you get in break in get work
I do think that there are ways to
do it but the first thing I think
there's multiple steps and the first step is
to understand that there is no way there is no
path if you want to be a doctor if you want to
be a lawyer there is a set ABCD to do it right
you go to school for x amount of years you get
your residency you do your entry you they have
mapped it out for you that's not like that in
film and I'm often asked how do you well how
did you do it well or someone will say should I
go do the DGA program and like go up that route
sure that there is that way of doing it you can
go do there are certain courses that they'll have
lined out like different networks will do it
like Warner Brothers might have their little
internal program and you can go in and study under
somebody and work your way up if that works great
that is a way yeah should you make an indie film
yes sure if you can do it and pull that off and
that is a way like but it's not a guaranteed wait
that's super important to understand there's I I
heard a screenwriter describe it once as it's like
we're all Blind Men with our hands against a wall
trying to find a way into the Magic Kingdom and
we're all feeling our way along and one of us will
oh we'll find a crack and we'll slip through but
the problem is the crack closes behind us so we
can't turn around and tell anyone behind us or get
in that way now that that was the yours specific
weird path in getting in and that's it so I
think how do you get in I think the first step is
understanding that there really isn't a set
path it's just however you can get to point B
do that that's so vague I know that's
vague I'm aware and it's maddening
I think there's a second important step to this
I would say that do not the Trap that I fall
into and a lot of us filmmakers fall into is the
well how did John get that job that thing it's
John has I've been on sets where I'm
watching a director work and I'm like
how in the world did this person land that
like they have no idea what they're doing
the minute your brain starts to go down that path
especially when you're around your artist friends
and you all start to spiral in this how in
the why in the world is so and so working
and I'm not it is a maddening exercise it
is a exercise and frustration and there is
no joy at the end of it and you will never
find an answer because it doesn't make sense
I think it's very important to watch your
mental attitude when it comes to that kind of
thing and the reason why is because if you start
thinking about that kind of thing all the time
you are going to start to
project a negative kind of energy
and that's the kind of thing people pick
up on if you're interviewing for that gig
and you're feeling extremely frustrated that
no one's brought you on it you may not even
talk about it but it's going to be there if you've
allowed your mind to circle around that drain so
I would say immediately you got to turn that off
and stop trying to make sense out of this madness
more practical steps though I think
that the first thing is you have to generate a lot
of work that now that's going to sound like what
do you mean I thought the answer I'm asking you
how do I get into this place where I'm generating
a lot of work yes in order to generate a lot of
work you kind of have to already do it on your own
but that doesn't mean movies that doesn't mean
you have to be making movies or television shows
because little secret my real that you can look
at the vast majority of the things on that reel
are not movies or television shows they are
other side projects other little things that
look cinematic they're just not part of
any kind of project that you will ever see
and there's really cool ways to do that and I had
a really big Epiphany and I know the last time I
was interviewed here I talked about this where I
had been trying to be a filmmaker for a hundred
years I was just struggling and just and I found
that I was angry all the time I just I was so
I was shooting a lot of live corporate events
where I'm just literally the camera guy in
the middle of the Arena like panning
left and panning right by some speaker
walking back and forth on the stage giving the
annual report on boring corporate I'm wearing
a suit and tie I am so far away from being on
set where it's exciting and there's explosions
and all of this I am just twisted and angry
and it was not a life it was not an existence
that I would ever want to go back to and
I realized one day as I was in the middle
of making a training film for I think it was
for like a shipping company like how to like
package something it was like as dry as it gets
and then I watched the movie Jurassic Park and in
Jurassic Park that movie came out when it was late
90s is that safe to say somewhere early 2000s late
90s somewhere it's over 20 years old right there's
a scene in that movie about how dinosaurs are made
remember this scene Mr DNA the little DNA cartoon
comes out and it's explaining to the audience how
dinosaurs were made and the characters in this in
the movie are all sitting in their little seats
and it's like a little roller coaster ride I don't
know if you remember that scene but they're all
asking questions to the animated thing and the the
host of the park is talking to the cartoon well
65 million years ago a mosquito would land on
a dinosaur and suck out some of the blood and
that's mosquito would get trapped in the sap of
a tree well that sap is now called Amber what
that is is a corporate training film directed
by Steven Spielberg here's the amazing thing
about that scene that film is like 20 some years
old and it's a scene that most people remember
it's stuck in their mind you get the things what
it stands out to you from Jurassic Park well when
the T-Rex breaks through the gate and the whole
Velociraptor chasing them oh yeah and Mr DNA
that one stands out and at the moment when I
was watching it back then I was like I wonder
if Steven Spielberg was all pissed off and and
angry when he had to direct this part of his movie
I pretty sure he wasn't I think Spielberg went
okay I have to find a way to communicate boring
material to my audience any superhero movie has
to do the same exercise by the way any any sci-fi
fantasy you have to do the same thing you have to
explain the tech or the superpower to the audience
in an entertaining way it's no different than I
have to talk about harassment in the workplace
video that I have to I mean these are the same
these are the working professionals have to do
this kind of stuff and I realized that well what
if I in my training film just to pretended that it
was part of a larger narrative what if it just
so happens in my little film about how to make
properly how to properly package a shipping
container what if I made that and pretended it was
part of Jurassic Park how would I approach that
differently if it was it was an internal switch
but at that moment everything changed because when
I would show up to shoot it I wasn't just going oh
just throw the light over there and I mean we just
got to just pan and scan the boxes no it became
can I make this box look cool it's a box how can
I like maybe if I brought a little Dana dolly or
do a little swooping camera move with some
sound effects and like you you just all of a
sudden you're directing a scene that's direct and
it became it changed the look of my little tiny
corporate films it changed how and the clients
started to see this excitement when I would come
to shoot their product because how cool is it for
them that someone is actually thrilled to be there
shooting the most boring dry stuff you can imagine
it changed everything for me that one decision
started to open the door to other projects just
like it and eventually and even today I now
have a niche where I create narrative films for
corporations they're like little short films but
they're big budget short films that I'm getting to
it's no different than a movie working with actors
writing a script coming up with Concepts shooting
and I got a thing coming up that's set in 200 A.D
with Roman soldiers like all because it's a
corporate thing it's all because of that one
decision to I'm going to pretend that everything
I'm doing is part of this fun magical Cinematic
Universe even if it's an interview with a CEO
is there a way I can make this how would Deacons
shoot this CEO talking about how he started
the company you're it's fun suddenly it becomes
fun and great and and that kind of thing can
immediately start adding a lot of work to your
reel I know a lot of directors who have been
in the industry for many many years who well
let me rephrase they want to be directors they
fantasize like myself they grew up and they saw
Back to the Future or Jurassic Park as kids and
and went Ah that's what I want to do I want to
create that and now they're editing for reality
television or shooting wedding videos and not
doing what they dreamed you have to get experience
directing and if you were to ask yourself
how many hours have you actually spent directing
like Beyond this is not on set this is not
onset as a PA or editing or even writing how
many hours have you spent actually directing
how many hours would that actually be that is so
vital because when you get your shot when someone
does open that door for you you better hit the
ground running and know exactly how to do it well
it's kind of a maddening thing to think about
right oh I don't have any experience directing
how do I do that well you don't always
need a camera one of the things that I
tried that really transformed a lot of what I
do is I wanted to get better at working with
actors so I invited a couple of actors to my
studio I gave them a scene from a play I had
no cameras and no lights and I just had the two
of them reading the screen scene to each other
act out the scene and I tried to see if I could
get them to a better more connected performance
that's it and it's important to say that this
was not a scene I wrote this is just a scene
out of a play that the actors just got on the
spot reading through it do the scene together
and it's so awkward and so hard for the just the
actors okay I'm seeing the awkwardness I'm seeing
the fact that they're trying to read the lines I
remember what to say I'm seeing that they're not
connecting how can I make them connect how
do I do that it is terrifying it it I would
have massive anxiety before each time I would have
them come over to try it but it changed everything
for me because now because that's directing
that's sitting there in the chair for hours
all right actors try holding hands and see if
that helps connect you more or sinking them
into their environment painting pictures for them
imagine that you're having a picnic on a blanket
right now and there's a storm cloud coming and the
rain pellets are just starting to fall like feel
the rain smell how the ground is feeling and now
action and see what happens this is all directing
and I would say that if you don't have any hours
doing it this is one way that you can increase
the amount of work that you're doing so it's so
important and you have to can you have to be very
Relentless about it constantly finding like
if you find that you're in this been in this
business for more than I don't know six eight
years and you've got one short under your belt
it's you it's time to step it up and
figure out a way to get something else done
another thing that I've done that's helped
me is I had a shoot once where it was just
a little corporate thing the shoot was on a
Friday we had a little grip truck of grip and
lighting stuff in the truck well that couldn't
return the truck until Monday so that weekend
I took the truck with the camera that I rented and
on Saturday we just went and got a couple actors
and I wanted to experiment with some intimate
like a love story I'd never tried that before
I've never done like a love scene I didn't know
how to do it even but I got some actors that
I trusted and they trusted me and we just tried
stuff and just I mean like a two a couple falling
in love and just what how to shoot intimacy and
just create this beautiful little love story
we didn't even have audio we just had visuals
it's on the it's on my reel it's just like as
something that we played with and tried it's it's
putting work out there that is super important
because when the window comes and
it will there will come a time when
someone decides to give you a shot you gotta
have something to show them you gotta have
some sort of real they have to believe
in you somehow so hopefully you're not
trying to scramble the night before to put
something together like this is how you do it um
another way to be working is you have to
you have to aggressively expand your network
now that people hear that and they think the word
networking and that is what I mean but that's not
totally what I mean I I think the better way
to phrase it would be making more friends um
usually when people think about
expanding their Network they
think about going to a networking event
which I think is one of the worst places
I mean that can be great but it's one of the
hardest places to actually Network actually
build your network I think one of the really
good place is actually a film festival
and the key to things like festivals screenings
things like that is not just meeting someone at an
event it's following up so my the feature I just
shot the reason one of the big the first things
that got going as far as it got got that feature
off the ground was me meeting the screenwriter at
the Austin Film Festival and the only reason
that I ever even got the screenplay from him
so his name is Dwain Worrell he was speaking on
a panel so I'm just an audience member I didn't
even have a project in the festival I was just
there to attend to meet people to do exactly
what I'm talking about to aggressively expand my
friend Network Dwayne spoke on this panel because
he had written it was an award-winning film
through Amazon called the wall John Cena's in it
Jason Aaron Aaron Taylor-Johnson guy from kick ass
I'm blanking on his name he's Quicksilver anyway
directed by Doug Lyman who did The Bourne Identity
and Mr Mrs Smith so wow Dwayne wow he wrote this
wow what a guy so I'm super intimidated but I go
up and I introduce myself and we hit it off okay
but I made sure to get his contact information so
that I could follow up with him later which we did
once we both got back to LA which is one of the
reasons to live in LA because a lot of people live
here anyway so we went out to dinner and that
was where it was really important to just be a
person not a desperate you're so great Dwayne
I want to work with you it was just what do we
have in common he likes Sports he like he likes
Sci-Fi Action we just kind of bonded over common
interests and we became good friends and then it
was when we had this connection then he sent me
the script for the abandon and when I read it it
was like wow that's the best group I've ever read
then I took that script went to another Film
Festival and I met a couple of producers
from the I did the same thing same exact
thing met them saw that they had made a
couple of films that were lower budget
after the festival was over I followed up
said hey would you like to go to coffee
sometime we could chat about whatever
can made a connection hung out with the guy
said I just came across this script that I
really liked passed it to him he read it and
said let's do it let's make a project all of
that came about because of just aggressively
making sure I was constantly meeting people
I will put on task lists each week
to meet more industry people usually
if it's by a month like this month I need to
meet three new people make three new friends
and I would say I don't limit it to has to be
a producer or an agent it could be anybody in
the industry really because you just don't
know who ironically I I made a friend in a
writing class that I'm in this is a super nice
guy that's really humble soft-spoken guy and he
I learned he just moved to LA so I was like oh
he just moved to L.A he's a director like me he's
right a director guy and just just seemed like a
nice guy and I kind of felt bad for him like oh
you probably don't know anybody in L.A you want to
grab a coffee sometime yeah sure so we went out to
Coffee me and my wife and just hung out with him
for a bit like what does your wife do oh she's an
actress like oh yeah I think I said something
like trying to make it in the big time huh
and I'm like well that'd be fun to hang out with
all of maybe going a double date or whatever just
being friends just again expanding the network
being friends making connections growing the
thing I said what we're having a cookout at my
place you want to come over like you you're new
to town you probably don't know anybody come on
out meet some friends it'd be great to have you
he shows up and his wife gets
out of the car and she is like
very a very known Golden Globe
winning actress and I'm just like
he he had no idea who his wife like it was it's
hilarious thinking about it but it all came about
because of this constant push to continue to make
more friends grow the network because that is how
jobs get made people the jobs that rarely don't
happen because of the meeting they happen because
you're hanging out at someone's birthday party
and we're like dude what I've got this idea for
a comedy horror we should you want to do it we
should do it like that happens all of the time
all the time that's how you get things made is by
having all these friends if the only friends that
you have are your mom and just your couple of
buddies you went to film school with you it's
going to be a lot more difficult for you to
actually get past where you are you have to
push beyond that boundary what about we hear and
we see in the comments we hear from people all
the time that you really can't get any meaningful
work unless you're related to someone I have heard
that myself nepotism is a real thing especially
if you live in a big Hub City like La New York
and you're competing against Kevin Costner's kids
or whatever Spielberg's son who wants to whatever
that is the reality that's who you're dealing
with well I think it's really easy to fall back
on that excuse and say well I can't because I'm
not anyone's son I grew up far away from Hollywood
now I'm not directing Marvel films at the moment
but that doesn't mean I'm not working right so
you it your future and your career is something
you have to grab a hold of we can make a thousand
excuses all day long about the reasons why we're
not making it if that's what you're doing with
your creative time then that's probably why you're
not making it yes good for them Steven Spielberg's
son I don't even know his name but good for that
guy like he's got a connection and a good end well
then maybe you should become friends
with someone like that maybe you should
find a way to make invent your own nepotism
like become best friends with a showrunner
if you can like that's how because look to be
honest like I would function the same way we
like to like throw the blame on this oh it's all
politics and it's all who yeah and I do the same
thing when I hire a project and I need a DP
who do you think I'm going to call do I call
some demo reel that I've seen online of a DP
I've never met or am I going to call Sally who
I know isn't awesome and she's super talented
and we've worked that's who I'm a call because
that's how we're all like that right we all want
to work with our friends and we all want to have
this solid team of people so it goes back to
just making sure that you are connected to the
right people I mean that's really it sounds
simple but that's really and rather than
making excuses as to oh I'm not connected
anyone I'm not so-and-so's relative
I think that's just an excuse to not go out and
actually do the scary work of becoming friends
with these people my personal humble opinion
but so when you've been to networking events
it's it's kind of reminds me of like these like
singles dances back in like the 80s and 90s that
I would hear people go to and like okay hey I'm
here to meet someone and there's like this weird
desperation and awkwardness whereas if you're at
a film festival or taking a writing class you're
engaged in something else and then if naturally
something happens or you approach somebody that's
a speaker it just it seems like there's just a
different way there's less pressure maybe yeah
the nice thing a bit Yeah because networking
events I'm not saying never go because there
there is value in them but it is exactly like that
it's speed dating and it's generally you everyone
is coming up to each other going how can you
advance my career it's a very self-centered way
to meet people it's I mean imagine if you were
trying to date somebody and you were going I'm
really looking for a wife or a husband I mean the
other person's gonna be like sure slow down there
Cowboy like I don't even know your name right what
do you do Jason that's right yeah yeah and I'm
looking at your watch and the car you're driving
if I'm and it happens and I'm not even like
anybody and if people find out I'm
a director and then they're an actor
director like you just feel the energy of like
this it's a it's a hard place because everyone
is essentially feeling the same way now if I were
in that same plane and I've got actors coming at
me from this way but I look over there and there's
a an investor I'm not up to you you want to make a
movie it's that same I mean it's human nature yeah
it is human so I think finding I think in if you
are at the networking event there is a positive
way to go about it and I think that would be
to try to remove the desperation from it go to the
event without the mindset of I have to get a job
just like you wouldn't go on a date saying I
have to find a partner it just puts so much
pressure on this precious little connection
that you're trying to make if you just remove
that from the equation and just say I'd like to
just make a friend that is so much easier because
oddly enough some of the best connections I've
made at things like that are usually someone like
the the person that's serving the hors d'oeuvres
like hit it off with so-and-so and like isn't this
whole thing such a Croc man people come down
here they're so desperate hahaha what do you
do oh I'm my name's Johnny and I I'm a DP and
I actually just I'm just doing this for extra
work what you are in a way and then all of a
sudden you're friends oh it's so much easier
to do that do it that way to take the
pressure off this desperation but a
film festival or riding class those are great
because the focus is not on you as much it's on
either their film or your film or writing glass
is a good one because it's like you're focusing
on a craft of like getting better you're meeting
other people also with similar goals they're all
there to improve their craft and and driving
towards this direction not this direction I
mean yes we're all trying to make it but
we're all looking this way and you just
happen to be looking at the person next to
you and you're just kind of becoming this
making a bond that way so it's a much easier
way to make friends and to build a team
Jason when you were starting out in this business
what attitudes did you have that were wrong
in terms of how the industry worked or
how to conduct yourself in a meeting
[Music] there's a saying that
youth is wasted on the young
I think what that saying means is that
we especially when we come out of film
school or school we we just have this inflated
sense of who we are of how brilliant we are
that is the number one killer of careers
that I think that there is and just having
this over inflated sense of what you can do
and I definitely suffered from that because I
we all who do this dreamed the big dream we
all watched that movie there was probably a
movie that you saw when you were young and
you were like I can do that and we all and
it's probably true that's the thing and then
we just start to build this framework of who
we are as people and then you actually get
into the world and start to try to work and
nobody looks at you like that especially because
well what have you done you're just you're 20.
that really was was a blow having a more of an
ego than I deserved if that makes sense I think
I never and one of the things that really tripped
me up for years and it still has Ripple effects
to this day is that I didn't understand the
importance of a mentor how much time that would
have saved me if I had just found someone to tell
me what to do because I had no idea we're just
stumbling around in the dark like how do you get
the first job on set who no one told me how to do
that so years had spent trying to figure out even
how to get an internship like my God it's so hard
so being humble enough to just say please give
me some advice because I'm I'm just want to learn
that kind of thing it's so those are both
probably fall under the humility umbrella as
far as the things that I did wrong I also think
that there is a that's the best way to say this
putting too much importance on this I'm going
to direct this two minute short or whatever and
putting so much importance on it that you end
up it it ends up breaking under the pressure
like just getting so wound up and so full of
anxiety over this one little opportunity that
you have that you end up locking out all of
the creativity you become Vision locked into
something that isn't working that kind of thing
can really kill you yeah because you want it
so bad yes and you're so you because you want
it so bad and because you want to do it right
and and to eat there is a real pressure
to the fear of making a mistake
and that is something I wish that I could have
understood a lot earlier is that it's is if I
wish someone would have come to me and said it's
all right to mess up sometimes if you look at some
of the greatest moments in cinematic history
they were generally mistakes or improv lines
from an actor or some sort of something didn't
go quite right and that's the thing that's on
the film because it just had this real magical
to it when you're putting so much pressure on
making it absolutely perfect like you and Afraid
of the mistake you just kill all your creativity
that's such a dangerous spot to be I wish
someone would have told me that and I think
one of the things I've noticed from
filmmakers who are very successful
is they have this very simple work ethic
that no one taught me that I wish I had known
and that is like for example I I know a
couple screenwriters and they're I they're
work ethic is almost identical they have a
set time they get up every day and they do
their morning routine whatever it is brush your
teeth work out whatever turn off their phones and
for a couple of hours block they write right
and right and right and right and right after
the end of that little block of time whatever
they said usually it's at least an hour or more
they take a break they take their lunch they turn
their phone back on they check their Facebook and
whatever and then they turn it off again and they
write and they write and they write and they write
and they write and then they cut it off and now
they're free to relax I I don't think I've ever
even heard of that done in any kind of filmmaking
class no one ever said to me like you need to be
super disciplined and guarded with your time to
make sure that you are honing practicing working
on your craft for set hours every single day I
didn't do that man a long time long time years so
in those years they slip in they slip by
and suddenly it's a decade and you just
aren't getting better you're stagnating you're
circling things right so I wish someone would
have mentioned that early on because it would
have also really helped this is how people when
they break through at Young ages it's because
they've been more disciplined about that kind
of thing I'm convinced of that where you
see them come out of the gate and it's
like dang how did this guy get so good at 25.
probably because they were more disciplined
very focused on their craft that means
being all alone probably working on a script
studying reading without looking at their
phones and all of that kind of stuff
but when you're young and you're thinking about
dating or whatever it is the distractions of life
it's it really will get in the way of of your
progress it'll just make it take a lot longer
I knew someone who didn't have a cell phone
when they first came out because they had such
pressure on them to be accountable for certain
people that they wanted their time in the car
to be uninterrupted and everyone would go why
doesn't this person have a cell phone and the
person would say that's my time when I'm driving
this is before driving on with that this was this
is early on when before it was this taboo as
it is now in dangerous but they were just like
no that's my time and and that's what I'm thinking
that's where I'm doing things I need to do for for
my day and I don't want to be disturbed I think
that's super vital it's really interesting to me
because this is something that I've fought for
in a nice and simultaneously struggle with is
this idea of I'm going to take from 8 AM to 10
a.m and I'm going to work my craft oftentimes
for me that's writing something but the minute I
do that the minute I hit do not disturb my phone
and start hitting keys my eyes drift over to that
phone and I want to see if anyone's messaged me
it is unbelievable that's called resistance
and it is a sneaky little bastard like it
it's it's I don't know where I think it comes from
a lot of places for a lot of people like fear of
success whatever you want to call it but it is
Sinister the self-discipline that it takes to
actually go no I'm going to take this phone I'm
going to put it in the other room and I'm going
to focus I'm going to turn off my email turn off
the messages on my laptop turn off social media
and I'm going to focus on my craft for this too
straight over I actually got an hourglass that
has a one hour timer on it I just flip it over and
I'll watch the sand go through and force myself to
do it but every day it's a struggle every single
day that resistance thing wants to fight you
but consistently the people I know who have broken
through did that and they did that for years where
and what's crazy is going back to what I said
at the beginning they create an enormous volume
of work because they're so dedicated if you're
finding yourself where you're working all day
long on whatever it is that you're working on it's
probably some sort of day job that you don't love
and then you sit down to write a screenplay that
night for like 30 minutes while you're checking
Facebook you're you're just gonna take you're
just extending it out you're just like you're
gonna take 30 years to actually get a meeting
at that rate yeah so I think it's important
to pay attention to that resistance because it
looks like different things to different people
also do some people for people Pleasers they
have the people-pleasing disease and they want
to be able to be there for individuals they
want to be present for friends and family but
there can be demands so yeah yeah
this business this business is
I found that there is this intense amount
of anxiety attached to this industry I think
there's a lot of that attached to life in general
this is not just me talking but if you look at
societies worldwide and the amount of people who
feel anxiety depression and those kinds of things
there is so many people taking antidepressants
so many people dealing with this that they find
traces of it in the drinking water and we've seen
that I mean it's very well known in La there's so
many people on Prozac or whatever that it's
secreted and it ends up that's why we have to
have filters on all our sinks because it's all
in there well what's going on why is there so
many people so anxious and so stressed out and so
depressed I think that that that's already there
and then it's exponentially harder in our
own industry and I think that that comes from
and I hate this part of our industry this comes
from this place where there's there's definitely a
looking down the nose at certain kinds of projects
so like if you I'll give you a perfect example I
was years ago I was looking at joining the DGA and
my bread and butter oftentimes is doing commercial
corporate stuff and a lot of that's non-union but
that pays it keeps the lights on keeps keeps me
working and it's it's actually great it can
be really great fun work and fulfilling work
I asked them so if I go Union can I still do
non-union work and they're like well it's probably
not a good idea I'm like man I don't know if it's
a good idea for me to join at this point because I
can't just stop working what am I gonna do go bag
groceries until I get a union job and they said to
me when you decide to take your career seriously
then you go ahead and come on and sign up with
us that right there is exactly what I'm talking
about it's this little bit of arrogance with these
projects over here are legit Marvel movie whatever
you high-end music video Marvel whatever you you
have these little category of movies movies
I've heard of or a TV show that I've heard of
these are the legit ones everything else
over here if you're making a wedding video
or a whatever like those aren't legit those aren't
considered and you're and when people ask you that
anxiety-induced question what are you working
on and the only thing you're working on is a
Colgate commercial it's this flood of anxiety
that comes up it's everyone I know struggles
with it they struggle with it especially when
they're not working when you haven't when you're
going to that event or even to a friend's house
because that the question is inevitably coming
what are you working on and if you haven't been
working what are you going to say like it is so
oh it just it just fuels us all and even people I
know who work a lot struggle with the same thing
and I've spent a lot of time trying to
figure out what that is and how to how
to work with it and I do think there are ways
to fight it I think the number one thing is
changing your relationship to anxiety
because when we experience it when it
crops up we see it as a negative right it doesn't
feel comfortable there is a method in that I've
heard that I've practiced through meditation
called noting and that means when you feel the
negative feeling or I shouldn't say negative the
feeling of anxiety comes out to take one second
and step back from it and go okay I'm experienced
anxiety is this positive or negative anxiety
positive because there is positive
anxiety positive anxiety would be like
oh I got this big pitch meeting tomorrow at
HBO or my film's in the contest I hope I win
that's positive that's cool like I'm about to
screen something oh I hope my friends like it
that's exciting right that's a good kind of
anxiety and when you're experiencing it and
you're taking a second to look at it and
go oh well of course I'm on edge because
my film's about to scream this is that's
a good that's okay and it's okay to feel
that there's also negative anxiety like
why Won't Anyone hire me things like that
now when you note these feelings it's I think
really vital to not judge it it you are not trying
to change it you are just recognizing it I'm
feeling anxious because rent is due and I haven't
been working okay well what that's a rational
fear that is of course who wouldn't feel anxious
there's something about just giving yourself a
little permission in some of those cases to just
be okay with it okay yeah this is a real threat
I need a place to live or whatever because you
don't want to get into the Trap of being anxious
because you're anxious because that just does this
right so noting like just recognizing it and
then changing your relationship to what it is
you can also take a look at it
and is this a thinking or feeling
kind of thinking would be rent is due this is
a faction it's due on the first and I don't
have it that's a fact feeling is man every time
it gets cloudy and rainy I just feel down like
that's a feeling so again you're not changing
it you're just changing your relationship to it
when it rears its ugly head and going oh it's a
it's a negative feeling and it's just a feeling
okay well what I like hot chocolate I'm gonna go
get one of those and just recognize it for what
it is I'm not going to try to change it I'm
just going to be okay with it I think that's
a that's a huge huge first step of dealing
with it the second thing I would say is that
you really need to pay attention to the
people that you hang around with because
they say misery loves company and what that
means is when you get into a whiny mood like
finding other people to whine with there's a lot
of power in that and it all it does is it it just
feeds on itself it becomes the Sloop and you can
end up becoming more angry and more frustrated
I would say challenge yourself to to be around
people who are relentlessly optimistic or try to
change your group's mindset to hey I know we're
frustrated that we haven't been working but
what if we just made something ourselves in fuel
some hope into this group that you're in if you
can't change your group right or find a different
group I think that's super super important um
the third thing I would say that I I think
this has been a big one for me is that
they say that the number one way to fight
feelings of anxiety is to find a community
anxiety loves it when you're alone depressed
people when people commit suicide they're
not in groups they're by themselves there's
reason for that one of the best ways is if
you're surrounded by people who especially in an
optimistic positive environment and I would say
that this group shouldn't be filmmakers somewhere
else now I think and it's even better if it's
active like something physical but it can be
kickball league or knitting or martial arts or
ballroom dance or horseback riding just some sort
of community regular Community activity where you
are plugged into a bigger family of people that's
not filmmaking related is so incredibly powerful
I personally I found Jiu Jitsu that was my
Big it really helped me a lot and because
in Jiu Jitsu I took it for self-defense they
say that judges is one of the best martial
arts for self-defense because in street
fights things generally go to the ground
and when you're on the ground how do you deal
with someone on top of you trying to choke you
so I started getting into that and the thing
that's here's what happens in my own Journey
I'll be anxious about something anxiety rears
its head ah why did I get that job or whatever
I won't want to go it's one of my buddies
from class will go dude bro you coming
yeah I'll be there I go to class I'm feeling I'm
sitting in the car in the parking lot ah I should
go home and work on that script or whatever no I'm
the class is starting in two minutes I'll go in I
go in the minute I hit the mat and so some kid is
on my back trying to actively choke me guess what
I'm not thinking about anymore I'm not thinking
about the fact that that agent never called me
back I'm not thinking about the thing that's due
tomorrow I'm thinking about not getting choked by
this animal that's behind me that is and when
I'm done and it's a not only is it an amazing
physical sport like you are exhausted by the
end but it's a huge endorphin dump you're just
like foom and you're around a whole community of
people who are learning a skill getting better
focusing on something else they're making their
lives better these are people they all have their
own interesting and Rich lives you are out of that
artist Community for just a second and you're just
enjoying some great social time in another group
I come back from that and I am super charged when
it comes back oh oftentimes I'm on my way home
like I know what to say to that guy to get him
to call me back yes that's what I'm gonna it's I'm
usually on a huge Euphoria high at the end of it
community community community is so important
like I would highly recommend and I know that
the first step to doing that it's always hard
like to they say in Jiu Jitsu the hardest spell
to get is the white belt because it's forcing
yourself out of the house into this straight
group of strangers for the first time
but man please go out and get that done
and finally I would say when you if you
find yourself dealing with it there is
a lot of comfort in the fact that if you are to
to make sure that you are working on your craft
continuing to make progress every
day there is a lot of comfort when
you get to the end of a year and realize
you wrote three screenplays that year that's
that feels really good or you took a whole writing
class and graduated or whatever it is like that if
you are not continually like getting better
and practicing and feeling yourself improved
that feels really good that that can also
because you'll know at the end of the day
at five o'clock when you log off and you decide
to stop and put writing aside for a minute
you can go play video games in peace because
you put in the work that feels nice you can
relax because you did your work for the
day that that's a really satisfying feeling
did you ever need to use any of the moves
in Jiu Jitsu in real life in real life
let me think well interesting story so in my own
journey I I had some very aggressive fathers so my
both were bullish both had a lot of street fights
so as a kid I grew up feeling utterly powerless
this really carried over in a career by the
way like as I would approach people that I
was intimidated by like that inner feeling
of powerlessness was really strong and so
when I went into Jiu-Jitsu I was absolutely
terrified like to I was essentially finding My
Own Strength I was taking class for about a year
and a lot of at least the school that I attend is
all about self-defense it's just someone on the
street comes up to you and does this here's some
things you can do at least to keep yourself safe
anytime I'd ever been in an aggressive situation
it looked like something was about
standing in a bus stop in some aggressive
was going to come up I'm absolutely
terrified and and wish I could run away
right before the very first day of
shooting the abandoned my last feature
I hear a crash downstairs in the house that
we're staying in it's three o'clock in the
morning I get up out of bed I'm totally drowsy
my dog is freaking out I walk downstairs and
there's a guy standing in the kitchen now it
was the weirdest most surreal thing because
I was I was still just a very new practitioner
of Jiu Jitsu I didn't I'm no I'm no badass
but it was the first time in my life where
I'm faced with a potential aggressive person
and I felt peace because the way the
guy the guy was standing in the kitchen
leaning on the counter kind of hunched
I thought he was going to rush me um
but I'd been practicing what happens when
someone rushes you in class for a year so
I just in that moment I just looked at him and
I thought okay well if he rushes me that's okay
I know how to deal with this I can at least keep
him from getting to anyone else in the house while
they call the police or whatever we can get this
handled so in the end it turns out he was drunk
and he found himself in the wrong house now
I didn't know this at the in that first half
the second when I saw him in the kitchen for a
couple of minutes there it was real Touch and Go
prior to that I probably would have grabbed
the knife or freaked out or whatever but it
really did in a very positive way change it
was a great way to start shooting the movie
to just have that calmness in the face
of that kind of adversity was was really
it was really great and it could be inspiration
for your next script I mean how bizarre is that
did someone accidentally goes into the wrong
house but I guess right we all look the same
I don't know when it comes to inspiration for
that I mean I have will say that when you learn
some when you get involved with some other sport
or some other skill you're increasing your skills
in some other way it really does fuel ideas like
if you whatever horseback riding class you're
gonna be on that horseback riding you're going to
be riding that horse you're gonna be thinking man
wouldn't it be cool to write a story about someone
on a horse who's or whatever it's going to happen
it just will if you're an artist that's that's
one of the advantages to doing that but yeah
glad everything was okay yeah oh yeah yeah when
did you begin to realize that if you poured all of
your energy and passion into your art that one day
someone would give you a job when did I realize
or that you'd be discovered yeah yeah that's
a real that's an interesting question because
it comes down to the definition of the
word discovered what does discovered mean
I would say that I as a kid and I think probably
every filmmaker watching this probably feels this
way you look at whatever Raiders of the Lost Ark
and you go I could do that I wonder if anyone else
believes I can do that like it's I know I have
to convince the world that I can actually do it
now in my case
the people that have
believed in me and given me the shot
have not been the people I expected so
it was came it'd be like a best friend who
just happened to be in a position that they
could hire me they just like came from back
here and you're like wait what you're gonna
that's when I was hope it was like it was one
of those things where I always felt like I had
something to contribute something to give I
was just wondering how long it was going to
take for anyone to actually notice what I
mean it's almost the other way around it's
like I always but I think we're all that way
we all feel that way we all feel like we have
something special and you're just waiting
for the world to catch up to where we are
that could be a frustrating position especially
if you feel like no one's discovered you yet but
I have always found that when it does happen and
no matter which level you're on it does happen and
that that could mean a movie deal or it could
mean getting a nice job dragging a commercial
it always comes from the last place I expected
usually a friend or a contact of some sort yeah so
yeah and I think that yeah it comes
down to that maddening place of
how long is it going to take for everyone else
to discover what I can do this is where and
this is where it's so important to continue
to create and put out there stuff that you
can do there's a great quote from Ira Glass who is
the host of or the creator of This American Life
and he talks about how when we got into the art
whatever it is that we got into we all got into
it because we have killer taste and we always
felt like we could do this XYZ thing and then
we start to create it and we realize there's this
gap between what we're creating and what we like
and we see that Gap because we have good taste and
the only way to close that Gap is to continue to
create work lots of work thousands of hours and
that's the only way to close that Gap and if you
find yourself not creating anything and and you're
in this business just toiling away editing reality
television for years and years and years and never
actually making anything then you should probably
you're never going to close that Gap unless
you do it that is how people will discover you
because the more you do it the better you're
gonna get and eventually law of averages says
that that is what will happen come back and
ask me in a year and we'll see and Spielberg
is called yeah we'll see if that actually
pays off but that's how it's worked so far
notion of being discovered is is sort of an old
term I'm sort of thinking of like a talent show
from the 80s where you're going to be picked
and you're going places kid but it almost seems
like now they want to see how much work of your
own have you put in without someone picking you
it seems like things have changed a lot there has
been a change while the one thing that's changed
I think is that the ability to create amazing
stuff is is has come down to other levels where
you can reach it because back in the day to
create anything that looked any good you'd
have to rent these really expensive cameras
and big lights and stuff you don't have to do
that anymore I mean it's just the way iPhones
shoot looks amazing like really amazing so
there is still I think the Divide between the
the threshold of television movies working
with Disney on a thing that people have heard of
there is that little divide so that still exists
and there's there's that stuff and then
there's everything else but there is still
so much amazing work out there to be had they're
still and you can be I the discovery can happen
on those other little projects and that is
I think it's really fun to do it because
like for example I do a lot of work with hospitals
and hospitals a lot of times hire me to create
these little stories and I'm telling you they
are so much fun to do because they're little
short films that are usually really meaningful
really heartfelt you're working with actors and
and it is you're making a little movie you
get great practice and it is super super fun
and I was discovered from that based on people
that I knew and and just doing little shorts
of my own like they would they would see
a little short film or whatever it hits
a festival or something and then they go we
should hire that guy to bring do our little
thing that's how all that stuff happened so
you could call that a discovery now is it
gonna win an Academy Award no but that's
okay there's nothing wrong with that I'm
I'm doing what I dreamed of doing as a kid and
it is a blast and people may watch this and go
oh that guy's never made a multi-million
dollar thing okay you're right I have it
but I'm having a freaking great time making and
telling stories and moving people it is it is just
it is the most fun career that you can have
because you're telling stories and you're taking
audiences on a ride no matter where you're doing
it whether that's a wedding video or completely on
the opposite end with a Marvel film you're doing
the same job and it is really great so yeah it's
I don't know that answered your original question
about being discovered but I do think that there
is a when they're trusting you with telling
the story for their brand or for their whatever
there is a discovery process that does need to
happen they need to see that you have the talent
to actually manipulate and tell a story and
craft a narrative in a way that wraps up what
they're trying to sell or do or say for it so
hence the sort of corporate video that was in
Jurassic Park I think also in Blade Runner too
didn't they have a few like they'd have these
Billboards yeah these commercials well that's
right I mean most times when you see a Sci-Fi
act stuff like that fantasy they'll have
some sort of way to communicate information
that's that's corporate video one-on-one right
there and heck what better way to practice if
you are gonna let's just say you could look
at your life from beginning to end and you
knew that in I don't know 10 years you were
going to get to direct the next Blade Runner
well wouldn't it be good to practice and that
in that Blade Runner there's going to be a
whole time travel element that you're gonna have
to fold into it and explain to an audience how
it works wouldn't it be good to like kind of
practice that now with your with at T client
that you have or or whatever like it would it
be good to like kind of maybe because if you
mess that up who cares it's just the corporate
video that not a lot of people are going to see
wouldn't that be much better to do it that way and
then by the time you get to Blade Runner sequel oh
man I got this I've been doing that this is going
to be fun and now I have all the money to do it
like that's a great way to look at it why did you
see the Apple commercial around 1984. it's just
one where they throw the thing into the screen
yes I think so right directed by Ridley Scott
yeah that would that that Apple commercial
isn't that crazy it has this amazing look
this really cool story it never it aired one time
on television I believe and this is pre-internet
and it made so many Ripples and it really made
Ridley Scott's career like from there he went on
and did I think I think alien was after that you
might have done the Duelist at that point but yeah
that was because really Scott was a commercial
director before he became doing movies so yeah
I was Finding work in Los Angeles as a
director different from other places yeah
that's a good question so I've lived quite
a few different places around the country
I just grew up in Portland Oregon I lived in
Nashville for many years I went to I've lived
in Eastern Washington I lived back in Portland
and tend to La every single city in the country
has their own little interesting if you do
film it has their own little interesting Hub
for the most part most cities have like some sort
of Industry that keeps it going like in Portland
and Seattle there's you got Microsoft and Nike
and Adidas excuse me a bunch of ad agencies there
so the for the most part A lot of the work that
people do is in that realm so I mean you can
have a great career just doing Microsoft videos
and there's no shame in that and that's sort of
the industry that it's going to be and the only
difference between that and like in Nashville is
replace Microsoft with music videos it's the
same kind of thing probably a smaller more
tight-knit Film Community doing similar kind of
stuff and also great careers can be had by doing
that I've recently been doing a lot of work in
Florida and Tampa and there their industry is
HGTV I believe yeah his base there so they a lot
of the people that work there work there at doing
and then I think Ashley Furniture makes a lot
of their commercials there so almost everyone
I've worked with usually is spent some time
working in that little Realm so moving from City
to City that's not a Hub City that's the biggest
difference it's really just okay what industry is
here and then now if you're talking indie film The
indie film markets in those towns look identical
which is kind of funny and there's almost this
funny little divide between those who are doing
the corporate work like the doing the Microsoft
stuff or the Ad Agency world and then there's the
Indie filmmakers over here and usually those two
worlds don't intersect that much in a weird way
now I think there's a middle step as well and that
would be the Hub cities cities like New Orleans
and Atlanta and New Mexico so in those cities
tons and tons of work is happening if you are
below the line any kind of crew position makeup
artists and whatever gaffer grips ACS all of that
stuff you will work you can work as much as you
want and you're working on great big stuff you're
probably going to be able to really do quite well
and that is a if you want to work in movies and
even if you do want to be a director but
you're still you're starting out and you're
working your way up the ladder those can be a
great cities to go to because it's it's like
I can I have a friend who just moved to New
Orleans a few years ago and he told me when
he first moved there he couldn't believe how much
work was actually happening they were doing a big
movie and their base camp where all the catering
was where you met in the morning was actually
shared by two other gigantic Productions
three of them sharing one huge base camp
like that's insane I can't even imagine that
and he said that because boy if you live here
you could work as much as you want full-time
year-round full union rates all of it like
you could just clean house and work
and work and work and work work
so that does exist in LA but it's a lot
harder to to get because everybody moves to LA
to pursue film so everybody's a filmmaker your
if you came from Kansas City and you were really
good at and you had that corner of the market
on the whatever is in Kansas City you are really
nothing special when you get to LA there will be
it's not that you're not talented it's just that
everybody does that here like everybody's like
that la is those of you who don't live here like
the biggest difference is that La is where the
decisions happen so if you are above the line
writers directors mainly and actors who want
to be on larger things you got to be here
so getting on those projects in an above the line
position is a whole different game than anything
else that you have to worry about in other cities
all you got to do in say a Portland to get work is
you're probably going to bid on it by against a
couple of production houses that you're probably
friends with you're gonna hire them anyway once
you get the job so it doesn't matter but you're
probably bidding on it in some sort of way then
the budgets are not gonna yeah they may be all
right but they're not going to be Millions more
than likely and yeah it's going to be a little
a fun little corporate thing and it's going to be
lower pressure I mean high pressure for the client
but overall the grand scope of life not that
big of a deal La it's 100 different than that
you can work here and most people do
when they get here if you're trying to
get here and work as a filmmaker yes there
is work to be had is it work that you want
that's the question that's the real trick
because most of the people that he move here
well you got to work somewhere and It generally
will come down to do I work waiting tables or do
I work anywhere I can get into the industry and
that might be an assistant too some Rider you're
not you're not writing anything but you're their
assistant getting their coffee it might be most of
the people I know go into reality somewhere some
way is it the dream job absolutely not do they
like it probably not for the most part but that's
there's a lot of that kind of work below the line
stuff you might be running a camera you might be
producing but it's is not the dream job at all so
it's a weird almost like purgatory that
exists here because this is giant machine
and that's the best way to define it La is an
industry most of these other towns are communities
that's a huge Gulf of a difference so when you're
here you get you can get stuck in this filmmaker
Purgatory of like constantly working on stuff
you don't like like reality shows or whatever
and then you're making some money and you're
surviving but you cannot figure out how to cross
the threshold from that to all right I'm going
to hire you because you're a great director to
direct on this television show or Helm the next
Marvel film like that's a that's a much weirder
barrier to cross and that doesn't exist and if
you don't live here you're probably not going to
have to deal with that unless you're incredibly
lucky unless you just happen to be the one guy
who won that lottery ticket and gets discovered
by the president of Disney and brings you over
otherwise forget it it's probably not going
to happen so that's a real trick a real weird
most filmmakers you meet in LA are in purgatory
they're in that weird they're they're all writing
something they're all developing something they're
all all of us everyone I know they have the thing
they want to do they have no idea how to get
over that bridge but they all want to do it
I think if you're going to move
here that is an important thing
to understand because you've got to
work somewhere you got to make a living
um and I think if you understand going in
that your life will probably be taken over by
that purgatory you have to continue then to keep
working on your own craft when you're not
on set doing this other thing over here
that is the key to figuring it out is I've
I gotta live I gotta make a living somewhere
putting a barrier around that and going when I'm
not doing that then I'm going to work on my thing
every writer I know who's got an agent they their
agents always tell them or managers tell them the
same thing yeah I know you're working all day on
that TV show and I know you're tired but if you
want anything if you want to have a career of your
own at all you have to keep working on your own
stuff on the side they tell them that straight
up and every writer I know does that they'll
work all day on their thing when they get home
they eat their dinner they sit in there and they
write for a couple hours on their own passion
projects and that is how they break through
that is how they keep going forward it's harder
especially when you get married you start having
kids life starts getting in the way and they find
the energy to do that is is the biggest challenge
that leads me to my next question because we
have a quote from you that we got from our
2019 interview that we did with you what you do in
the dark when no one is looking that's where your
medal is that's how you get better do you still
Embrace this idea yeah no question about it I
yes it is when you're in your when you're young
when you're in your teens in your 20s we are all
going to school right we and then when we get
out of college most of us stop why is that why
do we all stop learning and taking classes and
honing why do we do that what is there is there
like did somebody on high like flick a switch and
say you've learned all that you need to know no no
but we seem to always do that
and the only way to do that is
the self discipline to continue on your
own when no one's looking all right
I'm not on Facebook what can I learn
what am I lacking in my directing skills
gee I really suck at working with actors I should
probably get better at that how do I do that well
maybe read a couple of books or take that's that's
where the real yes you you must do that if you
want to be the best you have to do that I was
I was working on a show recently this last year
and in the last couple of
years I was in a writing class
and I started the writing class because I just
wanted to get better at crafting stories it
just understanding how storytelling works on the
most basic level it was an area that I felt was
lacking in my own journey and so I yeah I'm
gonna do this so at night I was taking this
class landed this job and I'm directing all these
episodes and the executive producer pulls me aside
and he says because there's been a few people
that have come up to me and say and and said to me
why is the guy who's directing your
show taking a writing class at night
and he said to me he goes and they're telling me
this they're asking me this like it's a negative
and I said to them are you crazy it's because
he knows that life's a journey that you have
to keep sharpening and honing and pushing all
the time otherwise you stagnate because that
he thinks that's why he's got the job because he
knows that not because he goes I know everything
it was such an interesting thing to hear but that
that's an insight into how most of us think like
we get to a point where we think we've mastered
it and if you think that you probably haven't
and do you think that that goes back to what we
talked about sort of I guess a snobbery in this
business because at what point is anybody finished
with learning something yeah I think I can I think
I think a lot of the traditional snobbery
that we think of when we think of Hollywood
I mean I think ultimately stems
from insecurity this idea that
maybe I'm not if they were to be honest in the
dark maybe I'm not as good as I think I am Maybe
I mean a lot of the people that have treated
me poorly were people that were threatened by
me and I'm not saying I'm all that I'm just
saying all of us have experienced that where
you just there's someone that you run into that
treats you badly and you almost know on this gut
level that it's like I think they're threatened
by me I don't even know why I'm not trying to
like hurt them I'm not trying to beat them but
they are viewing me like I'm trying to be like
so it all stems from this deep deep insecurity
I think that's really a shame and a lot of the
people I think who are the worst offenders of
that are the people that don't continue to grow
they feel like this is where you'll
hear it too you'll hear it when it when
someone will complain about the young coming
up and taking their jobs that's where you can
really spot it that is someone who has it's a
it's a growth mindset versus a fixed mindset
it's a fixed mindset is someone who believes
that Talent is something you're born with
a growth mindset is some someone that believes
that Talent is something that can be learned
by continuing repeated Behavior now you may have
a knack a propensity for math or photography but
that doesn't mean you're a genius out of the womb
it has to be cultivated and worked the people that
use those terms like those kids don't know what
they're doing they don't want to hire an expert
well no it's not that it's probably not that at
all it's because they're hungry they're they're
coming up and and fighting for it to learn and
they're probably they're the ones watching film
courage interviews to get better the people that
are angry are not they're not they're just not
now they're all going to comment on on this
one and say what's that kind of but it's
yeah that's I think that's where
that comes from though I that
and I think if you are one of those people
and you're constantly feeling this threat
it's time to take a serious look at where you
are standing and where those feelings are really
coming from are you feeling threatened
because you're worried about your job
and if you're worried about your job why
are you so worried is it because you think
that they're going to discover you for
being a fraud maybe or is it because
I don't know like there's many
reasons why that could be I just think
it's it's time for self-reflection time
should you find yourself in that position
I think we can all think back to when we were
threatened of someone I mean I can picture
being 14 and being incredibly threatened
of somebody and now that I look back on it
it was because yeah I was afraid they were gonna
it was my little part-time job and then I thought
they were going to take my job and they weren't
they were just there for the summer yeah before
they went to college but it's if we look back
to things when when we did it we can say okay
well that was why I couldn't say hi to this
and then and then when it happens to you in
reverse then you go okay that's a fair point it
is a fair point because yes I've struggled with
that too there's certainly directors have
come up that I'm like frustrated with like
but if I'm being honest I would say it's because
I I could even I mean it's been it's happened I'll
see some 20 year old do something that I can't do
that bothers me because whatever and it's who
knows they spent all their high school years we're
learning After Effects and they just got really
good at doing VFX and they're coming out of the
gate with some amazing short that's like how in
the world did he and I feel threatened by that and
I want to treat them badly because of that I think
it's just that's not instead wouldn't it be better
and I'm talking to myself here but wouldn't it be
better for me to take a look at this person and go
maybe we should team up wouldn't it be cool to
like take someone who's got that desire and has
the skill that I struggle with and to bring
them onto my team and we can work together I
mean this is a collaborative art after all
[__] isn't that the way it's supposed to
work like you're taking all these artists who
are hungry do how much that would mean to him
or her if you did that and how hard they would
work because chances are they are looking at you
as a veteran or whatever wanting that approval
and and just begging for a shot I think it would
be a much healthier way of looking at it because
think about it that's what we all want that's what
we all wanted we all want someone to believe in us
and not be threatened by us and give us a shot so
and it actually makes me wonder if the those
of us who feel threatened who feel angry who
who if we feel like well no one ever helped me
why should I help them yeah or maybe I don't
have anything to give them because I never did
get a shot so they're gonna just surpass me
those are all hard questions to
to process I think if you recognize that that's
how you're feeling it's time for reality check
on maybe maybe you have gotten shots and maybe
you are further than you think maybe you are
someone of influence that does have a lot to give
and holding on so tightly to your position is is
I think it's like a cancer because it because when
you do that this gets back to what we were talking
about originally holding on to something when it's
trying life is trying to slip past and morph it in
your hands maybe it could grow into something
even more incredible than you you're imagining
right now like whenever you start to feel that gut
go and hold on to that thing like I think that's
that's a Thai time to like take a serious look
at where you are do you have to be a genius to
create a masterpiece oh do I have to be a genius
to make up masterpiece no I don't think so it's
here's the great thing about this industry is that
it's collaborative I think that there's a lot of
people if you look at some of these movies that I
think one of the classic examples is Casablanca it
was an absolute disaster in the making of but
somehow the pieces magically fell together to
create this incredible thing and that can happen
I mean there's a lot of I won't name names but
you there's a lot of directors that do one great
film and they're the rest of their films are just
terrible and you're like how in the world did that
first one end up so good and the rest of these are
so bad is probably a lot of it's because they were
probably had this amazing support team around them
to help carry them wrong and that's one of
the I'd say advantages to directing is that
I'm not advocating for this but you you can do
it and not know what you're doing and actually
it happens it's very common it's very common
because think about it like if your DP knows his
stuff or her stuff he did your director doesn't
have to know where to put the camera if you have
amazing actors and they're just spot on with they
just know how to do it and you're your production
designer is amazing you director you can phone it
in and be fine like your other departments will
carry you there's a great comfort in that actually
like if you come in and you have no idea how to
shoot the scene and your DP is amazing well they
will help you so no you don't have to be a genius
and I I think there's a comfort in that because
the insecure that maybe the potential insecurity
that's there of ooh what if I don't really know
what I'm doing I think not all of us struggle
with that but I definitely think that's a
thing I remember hearing an interview with
the guy who the the composer for Gladiator and
Dark Knight and Hans Zimmerman I remember hearing
an interview with him years ago where he said wow
I just landed this job I think it was the job for
Gladiator he's like wow like wow I just landed the
job to do the score for Gladiator I hope no one
discovers that I'm a fake it's like what really
you think that and I know there's a lot of people
very accomplished people who have the same thought
of what if what if I'm not a genius what if
there's some flaw in me that is going to keep me
from getting to up there no you don't have to be
so this is where it becomes really important to
make sure you're surrounded by the absolute best
really talented artists and filmmakers and
that's that's awesome in filmmaking it's a really
positive thing when your DP is better than you are
wow that's cool I've worked with actors who I can
tell would be amazing directors and they have such
good instincts they're out directing me sometimes
I could choose to be insecure about that but
better to go that's actually a pretty good
idea let's do that I like your idea nice
one dude so that's that's a really I think
that's a good thing now that doesn't mean we
shouldn't try that doesn't mean that doesn't
give us permission to just phone it in I do think
that we need to bring our a game and be prepared
when we're when we're working but no
genius now you can there's lots of people
working today that probably shouldn't be
there but that's okay it's all right that
right there is the number one skill that a
director needs to have is how to out think
all the problems all the time because they are
coming at you a thousand miles an hour and when
it's going great and things are all running in
the same direction that's awesome but when you
when you're faced with the worst that's
where the Testament of how good you are
really will come true when we did Kenobi we were
shooting out in the Trona Pinnacles which is
it's Central California it's kind of
Near Death Valley and it's this it's
there's not a lot out there there's this land with
these big it's a magical looking place these big
spiers sticking up out of nowhere but we're three
hours or more from LA everyone came in on this bus
and it's a TR it's a lot of people out there doing
all of this stuff and a lot of not just it's not
just a love story or something simple it is droids
and Stormtroopers and stunt guys and like all the
I mean a million different children and keep
in mind the Stormtroopers can't hear you when
they're when you're trying to direct them and they
can't because the helmet you can't hear anything
you also can't see anything because you're you
you have this much to see first day we had wind
gusts up to 30 40 miles an hour and so I realized
I couldn't shoot anything that involved dialogue
okay so how am I gonna deal with that and then
the props truck got into a car accident on the
way to set so we had no droids we had no speeder
we had no we had this big moisture evaporator
Tower didn't have any that didn't show up
all I have are some actors and high winds
so that is a perfect example of all the plans that
I had made all the storyboards and shot lists that
I had all went right out the window because all
of a sudden I have nothing to shoot like we can go
over here and do this oh no we can't because it's
too windy okay so all of a sudden I was forced to
severely think on my feet and basically rebuild
the whole film in my head and we started by
shooting inserts which is the complete backwards
way you're supposed to do it when you're doing a
a scene or show or something you generally start
with your master your coverage and then you figure
out oh we need the guy pulling the wallet out
well this had to be the total opposite of that
it was I could get away with like one line
of dialogue or something like there's a shot
in there if you've seen it where Aunt baru
as she's binocular she turns to the camera
the camera pushes out behind her and she goes
stronger that was during that day because I
had it was one line we would sit there we get the
camera set up we're waiting and the wind would go
action dang hit the shot and then that's it then
the next day we had a little kid on set and he
was so little that he didn't he wasn't quite old
enough to really understand it he was on a set
so it to him it's play time and costume very it
makes it really hard he's one of the youngest
actors I've ever directed so it makes it hard to
to how do you to handle because you can't be super
rigid about your schedule and you're shot list
because he's he's going to be the way he wants
to be and he's afraid of the Stormtroopers
and starts crying and it's just like so
your ability as a director to think on your feet
is super vital that's what that job required the
ways that you can fight that the ways that you
can fight maybe is the wrong word the way you
can prepare for that because it will happen to you
if eventually there will be days where things are
going to go completely wrong first is to prepare
more than you even think you need to like having
as many detailed shot lists or storyboards that
you can come up with is super helpful especially
for something like that where it's very complex
lots of moving pieces costumes actors kids really
knowing what you if you get on set and you're
going to be gone you're thinking you're going
to figure it out on the day or to put the camera
that's a very dangerous spot to be because that
may happen anyway whether you want it to or not
so at least having an idea before you get there
is really good but even that's not enough like
understanding I need to have this standoff between
these two people I want to start with this wide
drone shot coming down then I want to get this
over the shoulder but I really want to get this
intimacy between these two people whatever it is
I think that having a very strong background
in editing is the I won't say number one I
will say that's probably the number two skill
that you need as a director is really knowing
how to cut a scene in your head while you're
working because it does happens all the time
where you'll be on set do we have the scene
hang on so we got him we got him got the
master we never did we never got him pulling
the thing out of his pocket we should get that
but then maybe the sun's going down you have
time for one shot how are you gonna get that
and get your scene that there is no other way
to really get good at that unless you're editing
spending thousands and thousands and thousands
of hours in an edit Suite putting together other
people's things because then it'll just it'll
ingrain in you a reflex of what you're going
to actually need on set if you don't have
that you're just at a such a disadvantage
if you're in the position like personally I hate
being in the position of not knowing something of
not understanding how a camera works I don't like
that like I don't understand not understanding
the difference between an 85 and a 35 lens like
what does that mean if you find yourself in that
position I think it's really important to spend
some time in the camera Department to figure
it out because it just Smooths it out for you so
much when you're there so when it comes to editing
really having an understanding of
that so in Kenobi is a perfect example
the last because we had so many problems
from the weather and everything coming in
the last half of the last day of that was the most
insane day I've ever experienced on set it was
ours we were in a bowl the Sun is going down and
when it's down you're done period and you there
was money on the line there was an investor that
several investors that had ponied up large sums of
money to make sure this happened and you better
get it done you better get it done it's like no
and you are in the pressure cooker you are it's
go time so no time to like not know what to do
we were I had to go okay we have to kill the
bad guy go here go here throw the lightsaber
One Shot Two takes done move on and we were like
leap frogging into certain sets and the final
fight scene when he does the big lightsaber
thing we actually ran out of sun the sun went
down and dipped behind the little bowl that
we were in so we ran out to another location
where we could still see just like a foot of
sun on the horizon just a little bit and it
was two circles around him one wide one tight
and that's it but I knew because I'd spent
so long editing that we that that would give us
enough to get us the story we just barely got it
that that is such a huge skill that that's
necessary so the first one was being able to think
on your feet you said and then the second skill
a good director should have is just being very
proficient with editing yes really understanding
editing I think the third skill and this I would
say is number one and it's knowing how to work
with actors and I am continually shocked at
how that is a skill that most directors don't seem
to know I don't understand why that one is the
one that's shoved aside just today A friend
of mine who's a DP said that she said they're
working with an actor the lead of this movie and
the lead is not good and I said well hopefully
your director can direct the actor and and bring
up a good performance and he said or she said
no the director's giving no notes whatsoever like
he's he's working with the camera Department and
the actors left on their own the amount of time
is unbelievable the amount of times I hear actors
complain about this I went out there I'm doing my
thing I'm getting no notes I have no idea what I'm
doing if you understand what it's like to be an
actor it's like painting blindfolded you're out
there performing but you can't see it and if your
director is hiding in video Village back there
not telling you that is a it's a very it's a very
frustrating place to be as an actor and it just
astounds me that more directors don't spend more
time learning the skill and it seems to be this
Terror when it comes to it this idea
that working with an actor is scary
I'm not sure where that idea comes from I worked
with an actor I was a rather a director friend
of mine a couple years ago was helping her out on
set and she said she said I heard her say this is
someone else she goes well this actors worked with
Martin Scorsese what do I have to say I'm like
what do you mean what do you have you're the
director they want to hear what you have to say
it doesn't they don't care that you are not Martin
Scorsese they just need to know what you want so
the most common excuse I hear from directors when
it comes to this kind of subject is they always
say that oh well just cast the right person and
that will solve your problems well first of all
I think that's a terrible philosophy to have
because what that is saying is well I'm just
going to make sure that I'm going to hire the
right person so that they can do the hard work
that's taking all of the pressure off of you and
throwing it on someone else so that you can just
get out of actually preparing and learning how to
do it second of all it's completely unrealistic do
how many projects there when you're working on
something you are always going to have the one
person that you didn't cast the the I was working
on a commercial one time and I picked this act I
thought this actor was really good and they had
this great presence to them the client said no
we want this other guy and I was like I don't
think this guy has any experience I think he's
kind of new and in his audition he didn't even
read the lines they cast him because of his look
so he gets to set so I have no choice this is
the guy I have to work with he shows up and
sure enough it was his first time on set all
right so now the philosophy of just cast the
right people suddenly that's gone and now what
are you gonna do well what are you gonna do so
I mean the amount of films that are made where
the investor says I'll give you the money for
your movie but I'm gonna put my daughter in
the lead has your daughter ever acted well no
but you got a movie and you just have to make my
daughter look good okay so then how do you do it
how do you work with the actor oh oh no the actor
they're so scary actors are a different Beast they
behave differently than everyone else on set it's
like they're like the popular kids in high school
they're what I mean and you're the nerd the Dork
sitting there at the lust table and whoever walks
in and they're like they're charming and
Everyone likes them and they're so pretty
and everyone just wants to be be them or be with
them that's the actors are like that that's why
we always point the cameras at them because
they have that charm and they have that look
so it can feel like you're the dork in high school
who's got to go up and now you want me to talk to
this person and tell them what to do and they're
gonna listen that why would they listen to me who
am I so that's the feeling oftentimes that you
can get well the reality is they're a person
and oftentimes I find that especially when
they can be difficult to work with it's because
they're terrified they're they're just a person
they happen to be blessed with this beautiful
outer shell a lot of the time but that doesn't
mean they don't have insecurities as well and
the more they're left on their own without any
direction the more insecure they can feel I mean
think about what that must be like if you you
go out there and you do your scene and no one
says anything to you and you have just bared your
soul in some scene and no one's going good job or
whatever like that that that might even frustrate
you make you angry well with good reason right I
mean it's like working for any boss and the boss
is never telling you if you're doing good work
never encouraging you never to I mean it
would be very frustrating place to be so
understanding that they are just a human and
it's so funny because oftentimes I'll come up
actor will come up on on set I'll walk up to them
and I can see them trembling like you're if I'm
and it's weird because I'll be at my director's
chair and talking to the DP and we're doing this
over here and I look and there's the actor
and they come in and oh they're pretty and
and I'll walk up and I see him kind
of shaking it's like wow I never saw
that until I actually walked
up and made that connection so
the lesson there is I think really making
sure that they're recognized and that they are
welcomed and feel safe that is so important
to do to because what we're asking of an actor
think about this in the in the grand scheme of
a set if you're a cinematographer they're not
they are operating a piece of Machinery they're
bringing their Artistry to it no question they're
creating emotion with this camera painting
with light but they're not being vulnerable
they may be even if they are scared you're never
going to see it because they're behind the lens
the same with the gaffer same with a sound guy and
a wardrobe person they I mean if they're having a
bad day they could go and cry in their trailer
behind closed doors you never can see that an
actor they're they're naked in front of the and
everything that you've been building for years
with the script and everything is pointing at
them the camera is pointing right that's a lot
of stress on a person so when you see them walk
in you're in high school popular kid walks in
can be the hardest thing to do to walk up
and just say hey how you doing everything
okay just to check in and make sure they're all
right that is a huge move and that will be a
you think about it making them feel welcome
and comfortable even though it looks like
they may not need that do it anyway that is a
huge thing that will help you actors as well
simply and it sounds so simple to say
but they just want to know what you want
if you don't know what you want tell them
because this is where you can invite them into
your own space in storytelling you can say
this is a goodbye scene but I'm not sure it
needs to be a weepy one and have a dialogue
with them about it because that's where the
fun can begin where you're actually going
you're saying goodbye to someone who you've
been best friends with for years but they've
always been mean to you would you really be
crying as you say like what and you can start
to play well what if it's triumphant goodbye what
if it's and that's where it could be really fun
now you're going to start to see the actor
come alive because they are being allowed to
play with you and you're on the same team that
can really be a lot of fun I also think that
as a as a director what we do because
because we've been thinking about this
story for longer than everybody else on
the team like they're longer than the
DP the Wardrobe person we've been
in working with the story forever
and so it's very easy to and necessary in a
lot of ways to come in with your own ideas
about how the scene should look and yes that's
important but you want to leave a little room
for a surprise you want to leave a little room
for them to bring what they have to the table
and you would do that you do that in every other
department right you're you're going to tell the
DP I just want this to look like like the old
films from the 70s how they kind of had this Rich
color grain kind of looking for that kind of Rich
color grain in this kind of thing and I'm thinking
it's all shot on Long lenses and the DP may go
yeah but in that time those kind of lenses didn't
exist they did a lot of zooms instead of dollies
so what if we did it more zoomy lenses oh yeah
that's right that's right how cool is that that's
you creating together that's you allowing the DP
to kind of bring his Artistry or her Artistry
to the table do the same with an actor I find
it really enjoyable process when they come to set
they've been working their lines by themselves or
with their husband or wife or or sometimes even
just a recorder there they record it they have a
certain way if they want to do the lines well let
them try it I think it's it can really create the
fun sandbox when you're you bring the two or
three actors and have everyone pause the work
let the DP sit over here for a second and say all
right let's just walk through it a second and see
what's what you got let me see what you got let's
just let's try it boom walk through the scene now
they feel like they've brought something into the
table you're able to like okay that's cool let's
use this piece but I think what we want to do is
turn in this moment here and then oh yeah yeah
you're now you're working together that really
allows them a feeling like they've been heard
and that will just you could just you
can watch their anxiety just go down
another big thing to remember with actors
is that when you're directing this is super
easy to do because you're being hit
with a thousand questions a minute so
I mean it is you just did a take the dp's like are
you sure it's okay with this lens like this like I
think maybe we go to a tighter lens oh yeah okay
good let's swap to the 100 and do the blah blah
wardrobe person's like I don't know this shirt
looks kind of wrinkly and oh yeah cool is that
background prop looking okay and everyone's asking
and the actor is standing there on their mark
like is that all right like and you're all right
let's do it again you totally forget that they're
out there naked wondering why we're doing it
again and it has nothing to do with them so
remembering all right we need to do one
more we got to make a change on our end
you're doing just fine these keep doing that
exactly thing you're right in the right Zone
but we got to change something with the camera
we've hit a bobble on the cable whatever it is
like remembering that it's like you're
spinning plates on the end of sticks
and the actor is always on the end out here and
they you'd think that they'd be the easiest one
to remember but that's the first one usually most
people forget is that they're just standing out
there on their Mark waiting for someone to talk to
so just remembering to keep them engaged I haven't
forgotten about you you're still there it's all
good let's fix something over here or whatever um
I think
yeah that that happened a number of times when
they abandoned by the way where it was the abandon
is essentially one actor in front of the camera
the whole time and a lot of these same rules
applied right so the the premise of the abandon
is a soldier who's hit with a bright light when
he's in the middle of a firefight and he wakes
up in this room with no doors windows exits of
any kind you can't get a hold of anybody and
the whole movie is him trying to escape this
mystery Room well that means he's the only guy
in front of the camera the whole time that's an
incredible vulnerable place to be the the actor
that is like it was his first lead in a movie
and that's that's that's terrifying I don't I
wouldn't want that position like if I were to
lead in a film that's scary enough but the fact
that you're the only face we're gonna see in this
whole movie oh my gosh it was so important
to take the time to make sure he was okay
just a greet him every day on set see check in see
how he was feeling making sure he's comfortable
go through it let him try a couple takes to
see what he all of these same kinds of things
and then with him specifically there were a couple
times where we would have some bumps in the road
and this this leads me to a huge point I made
a couple mistakes there was a day where we were
doing some stunt sequences and and ironically
the moment I'm talking about is in the trailer
there's a moment where the character realizes that
something is very wrong oh no the big Discovery is
being made and he goes we were trying to do this
very specific shot where the camera is going to do
this big Dolly push and it it's tilting as it goes
and he's leaning on the wall a certain kind of way
and I'm and the way the film is put together
we had this camera that could do this it's
called a Lambda head so we could tilt it and
and the film plays with gravity a lot so we
would always tilt the Lambda head often times
to make it look like gravity was coming from
the wrong direction but when you look at the
lens and then you look at the stage it looks
ridiculous because the he's oftentimes standing
in a tilt and it's like I would start chuckling
because it's like I feel like I'm making Star
Trek in 1960 because it's just like people
throwing themselves around so I'm just like
kind of chuckling at the hilarity of it all
and I'm trying to get this very real moment for
him the cinematographer wasn't feeling well that
day and I'm trying to get this shot we were all
this is like three quarters away through the shoot
we're all completely exhausted and I'm giggling
at the monitor well here's the actor all he knows
is that people are looking at him on screen
and laughing right so understandably so he was
feeling extremely insecure and got mad at me it's
a dude I feel like my ass is hanging in the wind
out here and I and I I guess I think you're
laughing at me and I realize in that moment
that of course he would feel that way of course
he would think that he has no idea the context
of where I'm coming from but the poor guy
is understandably frustrated with me so
the point I'm trying to make is these things
are going to happen miscommunications happen
you're gonna snap sometimes you're gonna
say something that you didn't mean that's
gonna hurt somebody's feelings and it's so
important to own up to it to after that day
I actually had to we had a he and I
had a long long talk about like hey man
I never meant to humiliate you that is was never
my intent and I did not mean for it to come out I
was laughing at something totally different just
the comical nature of what we do for a living was
really more of what I was thought was so funny at
the time it was nothing to do with how stupid you
looked it no I would never laugh at something like
that like I'm here to protect you but I had to
come forward it was very difficult I had to tell
him and be very honest and really protect him in
that moment this happens a lot if you find that
you snapped at your actor some way because they
irritated you and you did it in front of everybody
it's a good idea to pull them aside after that or
the next day or whatever and say hey that
was out of line what that's going to do is
that's going to do this you're going to be as
vulnerable as there we're asking them to be and
it's going to put you on this even level with them
where you're both hey we're human we're trying to
do this thing there's a lot of pressure the Sun
is going down we're running out of time I snapped
I'm sorry can we get past this and just I'll try
to do better next time that's such a big really I
think important move to do to be willing to do
that that'll help you with actors quite a bit
usually if you are that vulnerable with them
their performance will go up because they know
that it's safe they know that you're all working
together trying to do the same kind of thing and
they once they are vulnerable vulnerability with
an actor is the secret sauce to good performance
because that is what this is why this is what
makes them different this is what when you
see Denzel Washington performing what you're
seeing that's so incredible is he's so open
he's you are seeing the inner workings the inner
Terror the little soul in there that's what's so
interesting that's what makes us all lean into
the screen that's that's what draws Us in it's
these it's these well people who behave like
that generally become actors who are used to
exposing themselves like that it's not normal
that's not what normal humans do that's what
makes them so interesting to watch that's what
we need but in order to see that you have to
make them feel safe feel comfortable they want
to see vulnerability in you its relationship
why is it a bad decision to make a movie with one
actor and one location why is it a bad decision
why is it bad to say having one actor in a movie
with one location it's just such a great idea on
paper because you read that and you're like wow
this could be so cheap to shoot which is true
it's true now I will say in the case of our film
that is what it is it's one actor in one location
and for the first several whatever weeks when
you're thinking about how cool it would be to
do that it's great but then the realization starts
to sink in that huh I have nothing to cut to what
are you going to cut to when it's one actor in
our case you don't ever get to see outside of
the mystery Room to see where he is that's hope
this whole mystery of the movie is where is he so
it becomes incredibly complex
to figure out how am I gonna
block this scene when it's one
guy on the phone the whole time
it becomes far more complicated than you ever
thought possible because you're now you have
to figure out how to capture scenes in
a way that continues to be interesting
changing up the camera angle keeping the camera
moving figuring out what the moments are that's
really difficult to do and we just really struggle
with that this and it also becomes a real problem
because in the editing room if there's a scene
that's dragging how are you going to cut around
that because if your actor is walking around the
room you can't exactly cut for time like if the
scene is five minutes too long and he's doing a
circle around the room which we did a couple times
well if I cut five minutes out of the
scene suddenly he's on the other side
of the room he's on the wrong side of the
room so you're really stuck with that so
that was a big issue that I did not anticipate
going in and how difficult that was going to be
what saved us on that front and if you are
shooting a project that you have one subject
in one very small location insert shots is what's
going to save your life now for us if you can do
this it's great but for us we couldn't do it cut
to the exterior of the house sure it's nightfall
or passage of time or something we didn't have
that option we were in the box so we were stuck
and I found like he's on the phone so like having
we had to come up with different ways of him like
sometimes he's got the phone like this but then to
take the phone and have him put it on speakerphone
and put it on his chest helped sometimes he
sets it on the ground so we we had to be really
creative about how to laughs do it so that like
so then if the phone's on the ground and it's
speakerphone well now you can just get a bunch
of inserts of the phone here and now we can up
cut to time and cut things out if we have to do it
that saved our butts the other real challenge when
you have one actor like that in one location is
that it can start to look visually very boring um
because one thing that we love about the
movies is especially is visual spectacle
and if it's one slap on the screen talking
the whole time it's like wow how am I going
to make that interesting so that also was a
real challenge for us is how how to keep this
visually interesting and one of the ways that we
did that was we continually messed with the light
we tried to make the room like another character
so we would actually show shots of the room and
then the room would shift in the way that the
lighting was so it actually starts from Bright
we had where we had a very soft overhead kind
of light it goes to the side it has more of a
nightmarish contrasty look and the light kept
it moved from overhead it started moving to
the side it kept getting lower and lower and
lower throughout the film until he was with a
flashlight and actually the stuff worries with the
flashlight is what looks the best but it continues
to morph and change the look of your room so that
doesn't look same same same same the whole time
that was something that I never
never considered moving in the other
real challenge is you really better
have a good set ours was a gray box
and it looked good like I I thought that
the production did a really good job but
man when you don't have any furniture like
keeping something in the background that looks
good that's tough that was a another significant
challenge which is why we decided to change up
the lights and and keep it looking different
we also change the lensing a lot too like we we
mapped out different beats of the story and each
chunk had a different name and look so we would
call it like this is the nightmare beat so in the
nightmare beat we shot with these kinds of lenses
with the light looking this way and the framing
looked like this so that it constantly morphed and
changed because boy you will you'll water torture
your audience to death if if you're not careful
so if you're yeah if you're doing a movie
like that where it's one character one room
I would really spend some time thinking about
how to continue to change the look there's
a movie called buried which is an excellent
film with Ryan Gosling where he's in a coffin
the whole movie and they did something really
fascinating with that movie where they used a cell
phone for light there's a cell phone a flashlight
a lighter and green glow sticks so each of those
have a different color temperature so it changes
the feel of the room as the movie goes that
was very clever very interesting way to keep it
looking different they also had a bunch of very
creative ways of filming in a space like that it's
a coffin that's tough but they would build long
coffins they would build deep cop and some some
were bigger they would also do really complex
camera moves and that's something we did as
well we would map out very complex moves where the
camera's going up and down and left and right and
the camera's kind of dancing as opposed to sitting
in one location and the camera just boringly
pointing at them that'll kill you if you don't
you got to be very careful your face with that so
we also I think the other thing
that really helped us was sound
and this is the constant thing I find is
overlooked in indie film is the importance
of sound and I'm not talking about mic
sound I'm talking about sound design
we it helped the world feel bigger by the way
it sounded and adding weight to this one room
and make it like how does a threatening room
sound now that will really it can increase your
production value especially if it we made it sound
like there was other Machinery outside the room
uh that that took a lot of work to do but
without that I didn't anticipate going in
how much work that was actually going to be that
took months and months and months of I did a lot
of the sound design on it so months of figuring
out how to create a room that feels like it's
a threat just auditorily yeah a lot of lessons
learned on that a lot of lessons learned and I
I think finally the last thing for us we had
another character on the phone phone conversations
are really interesting to shoot because it is it's
exactly it's one actor blah blah and you can't
see that if you're not shooting the other end of
the conversation it's just what's on their face
well there's a number of ways to do
that I think a lot of times they'll
have someone off camera reading the lines
to them who's not an actor now that is a
often I know I get for convenience that's often
times what happens but it's really doesn't do
the actor any favors I was really worried
about that with ours with our film because
our actor really needed to be vulnerable
and terrified and if we had some scripty
are you scared in the room I'm scared like
it's not gonna work how's an actor supposed
to get in the character when you're the person
reading the script is just some person who's
just there drinking their coffee and in their
Ugg boots like that's just not gonna work so
I had the actor on set the other actors on set
we actually built her her own little off stage
box of her own because she's in our story she
says in is claiming to be in a similar space
so we we tried to make her feel just like
that what that did was it it put them both
in a vulnerable position and now they can hear
each other actually on set as opposed to just
over the over the phone and they were able
to actually physically connect and talk and
work the scenes out together that was a huge
help to us and also allowed for improvisation
each of them had their own mics and so now they're
able to explore the scene together and that helped
us a ton a ton so if yeah if you're doing a
project like that I would highly recommend
exploring some of those options and if it's one
character on screen really paying attention to
how difficult it's going to be for them to do
it the kind of accommodations you're going to
have to do to make them comfortable because
that's that's becomes what it's all about
because they're the only one you're going to see
and so then are you dealing with almost two arcs
because you have the Arc of the main character but
then you have the Arc of the relationship yeah so
now you're working with kind of two you have the
beginning I mean not I don't want to give away too
much and and and but but I really felt that that
they were connected and that they had a bond yeah
[Music] without again giving but yeah I was
impressed that their conversations with each
other yeah that's exactly right that there is an
arc in the course of our story there is I mean as
all stories should have an arc with characters now
what's interesting about the behind the scenes of
that so the two actors didn't really know each
other before this whole thing began they kind
of met each other very quickly before the start
of filming so there really was no relationship
in the course of filming my relationship with
both of them was really key so oftentimes this
is going to sound really dorky but oftentimes at
the beginning of a shot and it's him alone in this
big room especially when we're doing the early
reveals and the terrified look I'd hold his hand
before with as the camera's getting all right
every real camera real sound I ain't quite unsaid
I don't know take lunch and I just stay there with
him like let them know you're not alone I'm right
here got you got you all right you ready ready
to do this yeah right right and then I'll back
off and then let him do the scene that eased
off as we as we went and as she slowly became
part of his world because the two characters meet
essentially on the phone and they get to know each
other as the story grows she essentially came
in and replaced me so I was able to back away
slightly as the Director and then she was able
to come in and oftentimes would hold his hand
during scenes especially when there was emotional
scenes or and I would like try things with them
because it was all about the connection
even though it's only on the phone but
I would say things like tell each other
a secret that none of us can hear like
well I'll turn the mics off and just tell
each other something that no one else knows
and it's such an interesting place to be
Associated as a director because you see
them say something and then they start laughing
or something like that and it's like what did
they what'd you say it's not for me to know like
that's only between them that's something that the
two of them can share but that really went and
and pulled them together and then as the scenes
went oftentimes I would let them just improv and I
would tell her what do you really want to ask him
what do you really want to know and she'd go
yeah boom and she and we'd be recording and
just boom she'd just go right into something
and try stuff that was such an interesting we
were all kind of crossing paths and I'm pulling
away while she's coming it was it was a very
very cool spot to be what are the steps
to developing and building a character
yeah developing characters so that's I think some
people have a easier time with that than others so
I learned this from actually I guess that you
had a on yours show Corey Mandel like where he he
actually in one of his interviews ironically said
that there are generally as a general rule two
kinds of writers there are intuitive writers who
see characters very clearly in three dimensions
and they just bleed on the page and that kind of
thing and then there are more conceptual writers
who are very good at the structure part personally
I'm gravitate more towards the intuitive side so
like and this comes as a director because when
I'm working with actors I can very quickly pivot
into deep backstories and things like that so
for me how do I create characters it it's a
little bit of an easier task for me but there
is a process that I generally go through that
starts with me asking like some questions like
what is the one thing my character would never
do that's an interesting question to ask about
a character but it can tell you a lot about who
they are so what would my character never
do well they would never I don't know quit
whatever would never quit Okay well that that
automatically that question can open up a huge
Rich story about why wouldn't they ever what is
it about quitting that's so pivotal to their core
you can also ask and I'll do this
what is one thing they would never say
they may never say I hate you or whatever now
of course in the storytelling realm you would
now have to make them do those things now and of
course what would they never say they would never
say I hate you well why wouldn't they ever say
that like what is it about that word that means so
much to them that they would never actually say I
hate you to another person it's a way of unlocking
certain kinds of things so that's usually
the first step in in that and then
coming up with what is your character's
major Focus not just as a as a story but in
their life what is it that they are aiming for
overall like for example I'm
working on a pilot right now and
I'm doing a lot of work on realizing what is
this main character's drive and this is he's
an interesting one because his Drive is to escape
his past right because it's he had a very abusive
past and and he is pushing and driving and running
he's an ex adrenaline junkie he's like pushing the
edge all the time looking for the next thrill his
Drive isn't the next thrill his Drive is to escape
so just going through and understanding
what that is really also tells you a lot
so that's usually where it begins for me I'll do
this little checklist and then what I like to do
in my perfect designing world all I'm a
morning Time Rider so I'll get up and do
my morning routine I'll take my little hourglass
and I'll flip it upside down I'll start the hour
clock turn off the phone and I'll start brain
dumping I really like the process of just like
just furiously letting my keys go on
the keyboard or notebook two it's a
different method but it's sometimes fun
to just like explore who they are what if
Izzy is just someone who just never
could quite find the right one just
she just tossed and turned her whole life and
just started exploring the path as it were of this
character and just digging into their lives and
never correcting anything but just like going down
and even as I'm writing she's someone that I can
never find love no that doesn't feel quite right
she's someone that did find Love She Found
Love early on but he he ended up leaving her
for someone else and now she's kind of like what
I mean like it's this it's complete immersive
exploration into my character and there's no
judgment there's no wrong stories wrong choices
here I can actually go back and edit in real time
but I don't erase anything that's on the page I
just put it all down there there's something very
therapeutic and really fun in the play of that um
I like to I will in life as I I could
be at the grocery store and I'll hear an
interesting conversation like here's a perfect
example I was at a sandwich shop one time and
I'm ordering a sandwich and the guy's like so
what do you want I'm like maybe I'll take the
BLT okay cool what kind of bread do you want
and I'm looking at all the Breads and it's
this really good Bakery it's just very
it's a great sandwich shop and I'm going
well you got a bunch of different kinds of breads
here I've never I don't even recognized what do
you recommend and he goes oh all our breader made
right here in the shop like you there is no wrong
choice I said oh so you're a sandwich agnostic
then and he goes who wasn't an agnostic and I
thought oh no oh no no no no don't say it don't
say it he goes our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
and it was so funny to me that he would
say like he just basically took my joke
that I thought was kind of funny and just
flustered down the toilet because clearly
This Guy's super super religious well
there's a great character for his story
someone who is so religious that they just that
everything it diffuses the fun out of everything
I I have a little note I use a Evernote in
on my phone and I'll like write that stuff
down I'm like oh that's an interesting
character or they I used to know another
guy who would always whistle and the more
stressful things God he would always [Music]
that's such a great little Quirk so I will keep
track of these things and as I'm exploring what
the character can do when it comes to quirks
and things sometimes I'll look through all this
list of things and go oh yeah this one would
really fit let me carve this into this person
it's helpful too to like take in the whole person
like what how tall are they how big are they
are they are they a ginger or are they bald or are
they like just to really kind of be have fun with
and and sometimes that involves like just doing
random Google searches or even Instagram like how
you can on Instagram you can hit the little
magnifying glass thing and it'll just pop up
this random feed of things you'll be scrolling
through and sometimes you'll see just someone
with the most interesting look they'll have
glasses with a really thick black frames and
their hair is a certain way and they have black
fingernails oh there's an interesting looking
person so that's a really helpful way it's just
like cataloging all these different people types
that are out there and random quirks that's super
helpful when it comes to creating characters um
as it goes and as it develops what I'll
need to do is I I really like knowing
their internet cores their inner what makes
them tick what do they believe what do they
going back to the what do they struggle with where
are they going in life I like to get more specific
about that as I develop them in the story that
kind of thing but that's generally the process
I know it's not a one two three step but that's
that's usually what I'll do do with that as I
go is there a fictional character that you talked
about earlier that one movie that we all see that
if we come here to La that we've like I wanna I
should have been part of that and that's what I
want to recreate is there a character or two where
you felt that like that's the character I don't
care if I'm playing it or filming it or writing it
that's the character well I can think of a movie
that really hit me a closing count as a Third
Kind was one that really just blew my imagination
the especially the little kid when he's because
I was really little when that movie was out but
the the little kid who was searching for
UFOs like boy I really identified with that
that one and and ironically around the same time
was when the first Star Wars came out and Empire
I always saw myself as C-3PO I that's such a
strange one like no one identifies as C3 video but
because my brother was shorter than me and he
was always the annoying little brother like he
was R2D2 and I was C3PO so like they're such
unique characters that's what they're little
antagonistic connection very much reminded me of
me and my brother and I I sort of loved loved that
and the idea of figuring out how to
create that was really really fun as
especially as a kid to think about that
yeah Indiana Jones is another one that
he's such a cool character and how do you
make that and that would definitely be one
as a kid I was definitely like anything to be
a part of the creation of a process like that
the man of Adventure and and ah so good with the
comedic stuff and ah it's so good it's so good
it's so good just yeah would you rather make a
story about good versus evil or good versus good
I Pro I think probably good versus evil
that's always a it's just such a fun
I mean my initial gut reaction is
making a story of good versus evil
I mean that is that's like so steeped in
our society as humans I mean Warring with
the gods way back in the day those are the
stories we were coming up with so I think
that's just ingrained in our culture excuse me
grain in our culture so I immediately gravitate
towards that and when I think of stories
of good versus evil they always sound epic
it's like making these big fantasy epics is
very exciting but that said good versus good
is something that's more fascinating from
a character perspective and I think it's
more challenging to write stuff like that
good versus evil is a lot easier to write
because it's the villain who wants to take over
world domination or something like that that's an
easy thing to go up against but if it's a good
versus good I want custody for the of the kids
husband and wife getting divorced they're
both good people each one wants the child
and they're both good people that's much more
that is very interesting to write it's very
it requires a lot more of you I think as a
Storyteller to actually pull a story like that off
because now you're trying to put the audience in a
position of which one do I root for that's really
a challenge that it's in a great way I still
think I would normally gravitate towards good
versus evil because it's just so great you know to
fight the villain or Darth Vader or whatever it is
ironically Darth Vader becomes a good guy at
the end but uh that I I tend to gravitate to
our stories more like that but I think as
I get older I do like more of the nuanced
complex human conflicts it just requires more
of you to write it it's more of a challenge
you talked about good versus good well you could
say Kramer versus Kramer yep that was good versus
good and that was an extremely compelling film
yeah and and difficult to watch and and want
to root for I don't know either side but in
terms of good versus evil it seems like the
quote-unquote evil always thinks that they're
good yeah so it could initially be a story of
someone who thinks they're actually doing the
right thing it's true and which those kinds
of stories if you're making good versus evil
it it is the back for about lack of a better
term the lazier riding approach to just make
them evil for the sake of being evil that is a
I guess you can make it easier to hate
or whatever they're just villains for
the sake you see bad action movies like this
well bad movies in general are like this but
I mean any writing class will tell you that
that's not the best way to make a villain
it's much better when they because think of it
in life no one actually thinks they're evil nope
I don't even think Hitler thought Hitler actually
thought he was doing the world of favor right so
if you want to make it compelling I mean I just my
previous feature before abandon was about angels
and demons and we wrote all the demons in a way
that they actually thought they were doing good so
that was a very interesting writing challenge
to how you make something as evil as that
justified in their actions how do they actually
justify what they do it it really pushes you
and it makes it it pulls you in a lot more as an
audience I think it Demands a lot more maturity
from you as the artist because you can because
think about from the actor perspective too instead
of this mustache twirling if you go to the actor
and say I want you to be the mustache twirling
villain versus I want you to they're trying
to take away your home that's how you see this
you'll see such a much deeper performance from
your actor that will in the end be more terrifying
I've had moments with actors where I will tell
them protect you're you're doing something
really heinous here but you're doing it because
you're personally offended by what they did to
you like it actually hurts you it makes you
even sad and you'll have the and they'll do
this performance almost With Tears in their eyes
but it makes it so much more terrifying because
you could tell how deeply they feel oh love that I
love that so is that good versus good I don't know
it depends on the perspective of the character I
guess but it's definitely a much more I answered
your question and now I'm changing my mind as I'm
answering it because I think that a good versus
good if you if you look at it from the perspective
of the character that's what the best stories are
Up For Debate yes Up For Debate
leave your comments below [Laughter]
how do you write a great scene
I'd agree riding a great scene is
is it one of the strangely hardest things you can
do as I think the writing piece of all the stuff
we have to do in filmmaking is the hardest
part that because that's where it all begins
that's the foundation that your entire house
is built on and when you're building this house
the easiest thing to do is you get your house
done and you're looking at it and you're like
something looks off it doesn't look over level
and you'll get notes and they'll the notes will
come back and say yep it's probably because your
house is red if you paint it green it might not
look off so you'll paint it green and it's still
off but it's because the foundation isn't right
and the foundation of scene work is is really
amazingly hard to do amazingly hard to do um
what I've learned especially over the last few
years in depth is how tricky it is to come up
with scenes that work and I think the best way
you can learn this is through watching plays
plays now every not every filmmaker but a lot of
the filmmakers I talk to they always say I just
can't write small I just can't write simple I get
that because oh I want to go into outer space and
fly ship around and I want to plant it to explode
well that's great I do too but what that can be
it can be the filmmaker waving their arms in front
of the camera saying I don't have a story so I'm
going to distract you with all of these explosions
so that you forget the fact that weather actually
really isn't a very good foundation and the whole
house is still leading to the left because you
never figured out how to write a good scene it
comes down to these very simple nuts and bolts so
if you watch a play you're watching scenes on the
most basic level and you're looking at generally
one or two characters or two or five characters or
something talking on a stage and you're pulled in
how are they doing that what is the magic
sauce that's making all that that scene work
it reminds me of and I think that those
filmmakers myself included if they want
to get better at this don't start by making
scenes with explosions start by making scenes
that are simple two people in one room this is
I had a friend of mine that used to teach like
a summer camp for drummer like a music I work
in a musicians Camp he was a drummer he would
teach all the drummer kids and he said the first
thing he would always do on day one is all the
kids would come in with all their drum sets and
they would set up these elaborate multiple Toms
and snares and this big giant sets he would
let them get all set up and then he'd go okay
I want you to take apart your drum sets and only
give yourself one kick one snare and one symbol
and the kids panicked because they suddenly
all their tools were taken from them
and they had to learn how to get good at
making music with just the kick snare and
that's tough anybody can sound great with
two kick drums but do it with just those
three little symbols same with scene work
so how do you make a good scene work well
it's so simple yet it seems to be lost on a
vast majority of people you have to be the
number one thing I think when it comes to
scene work is Clarity of goals and Stakes
Clarity that means knowing exactly I just had a
it's so interesting I just had a script consultant
take a look at one of my scripts he said to
me because what do you think you're best at
in your writing I said I think I'm
pretty good at writing action when
people read my scripts they say the action
is like usually really compelling and like
he goes what do you think you struggle with
the most I said well probably like the all
the things in between the little connector pieces
and the overarching like sometimes scene work and
stuff like that like exactly what I'm talking
about he goes why why they say that like no
I don't because because in action scenes
it's very clear what the character wants
they're trying to win the motorcycle race or
whatever right so it's super easy to write
this compelling action scene because I gotta get
over the Finish Line before the other guy does
very clear goal very clear stake I don't want to
lose the race so it's a it's a really compelling
scene he goes that's why your action scenes are
selling better it's not because you're magical
with words it's because me as an audience member
understands what he wants one is just husband and
wife talking about getting going shopping it's
just like because there's just nothing there so
this is super common and then we hear to
make all this more difficult we we are told
I don't know who tells us this I
don't know where this comes from but
on the nose writing right is considered bad
writing well what what why is that considered
bad writing have you ever wondered that why who I
don't know who initially said this but on on they
say that on the nose writing and when I say on the
nose I mean Clarity what does your character want
and where is he going what and what is at stake
if he doesn't get it well in order to understand
what that is that means being on the nose and very
clear I really want to get out of this house okay
but we're told we're there's somehow in our
filmmaking Society we're told that on the
nose writing is bad well why is that why why
who who initially said that that was a thing
I'm not sure who said it but in some ways
it doesn't let the audience really guess
and the relationship unfold it's
too it's just there's no mystery
to it you need subtext right yes we
we want this man we want it to be
we are we want we want to be so clever about and
making them figure it out right well the thing is
that's and I and I totally get that
because I'm totally wired the same way
like I don't I want to be more clever about
the way to reveal what the character wants
but on the nose writing what makes it that is
is it almost makes it feel that way because
when you see well done scenes when you see a scene
that just wraps you in and pulls you right along
the writing is pretty on the nose but they are
essentially giving us what makes things feel on
the nose is when I'll give you an example you see
an action like a bad action movie and at the very
beginning of the action movie usually there's
a scene like we got to go in and kill that guy
because he killed my sister and I'm going to take
revenge on the blah blah and it's just long drawn
out like setup of okay we gotta go kill the bad
guy because he killed my sister and it it feels
really clunky and on the nose the reason why is
because we didn't ask for that information that's
what makes us feel on the nose as an audience
member you're like you're handing me all of this
stuff I didn't need but if you hand it to me
in a way that makes me go what is his name
then reveal it it's on the nose but it's
when I ask for it well what is it about
this guy that bothers him what grievance
did this villain do that makes it so bad
killed his sister you're revealing it at the
right time that is a real trick when it comes to
putting a scene together properly but
where it starts is it starts with I think
not writing in final draft it starts with very
clear outlines and mapping what you want so
and this is where
there's a simple goal and stake so what I mean by
that if you don't know what that means that means
like I want to get out of the house but the thing
that's often missed is what are the stakes of that
what happens if he doesn't get that or she right
what happens if I don't get out of the house well
if it's just I'm gonna be bored well it's going
to be really hard for me to get behind that as a
story you have to come up with a way to make that
so terrifying if they don't actually get there
if the house is on fire I'm gonna get third
degree burns if I don't get out of the house
now that Stakes if the house has ghosts in
it now there's a reason to get out of the hat
like that you're you're tying Stakes to it but
that's just the beginning because you also need
someone against those stakes and goals usually
with their own stakes and goals attached to them
and if you really want to make a scene work you've
got to come up with a way to put those two things
against each other so I want to get out of the
house but character B wants me to go upstairs
that's a conflict and if me
going upstairs means I'm just
I'm thinking off the cuff here but like
if I want to get out of the house because
I don't know why I'm going so dark with this but
if there's a demon that's trying to take my soul
right so okay let's just say that's the
story there's a demon that wants to take
my soul and he's ah and I gotta get out of
the house well that's huge steaks oh my gosh
character B walks in and says I need you to go
upstairs okay so so now for me like that's a huge
deal there's no way I'm doing it but for them okay
let's imagine there's a bigger threat outside that
the outside person sees like maybe there are
zombies outside and if you go outside you're
going to die so we need everyone to go upstairs
now you have a conflict so that's a scene that's
that's two characters that have two different
goals and they're they're running into each
other I need to get out of the house the other
one's going no you need to go upstairs well if
I stay in the house my soul is gonna be taken by
this demon but if you go outside you're going to
get eaten by the zombies well if someone's gonna
someone needs should win right that's what makes
it compelling conflict now I went way monster
movie to horror movie or whatever with that
idea but that is essentially the essence of what
makes a great scene taking two characters that
each have differing goals and aligning
them so that they are hitting each other
probably a better example would
be someone needs to get into the
bank vault right I need to get in there okay I'm
writing the scene I need to come up with a way
that's my goal I have to get in the bank vault
and I don't know get my marriage certificate out
of the that's the I am a marriage certificate
I need to go in there and I need to get it I'm
all in one with a key how it works safety positive
safe deposit box my marriage certificates in there
I got the key it's handcuffed to my wrist
I have to be the one to go in and unlock
it and of course you've got to have the other
usually there's two people that unlocks the
thing together how it works at the bank let's
say that's your goal okay that makes sense
well how am I how do I make this goal exciting
well we need to create someone with opposition
all right but we can put a security guard there
now I think most people when they would write
a scene like that we could make a security
guard there that doesn't want to let them in
okay so the security guard's there he doesn't
want to let them in the room and you could
just oh he just lays him he doesn't want to
get off his chair and open the door I think
does that do you would you think that that is a
scene that could work and they be getting this
argument about how he's just lazy and he just
likes his chair he just wants to stay there do
you think that would be a scene that would
work only if I discover later that actually
he's part of a larger ring that's stolen these
marriage certificates and he's selling them
on the dark web true so if you see yeah he seems
lazy and he seems innocent enough but actually
no because your certificate is actually not
in there anymore oh that's interesting okay
and he doesn't want you to know that so
I guess if he's just lazy I need a good
reason why he's lazy yeah right okay so a
lot of times you'll see scenes like this
where it's like I need to get in there
to get my thing out of the drawer well
and the other person just doesn't want to do it
well and then they break into this argument so
this is very common you'll see this kind of scene
all the time and as two people in this argument
but what's missing there are Stakes for both of
them number one and the security guard has no goal
like he's not really he's just resistance he's not
he's not an antagonist necessarily so what that's
doing is it's diffusing your scene it's going to
help drag it down instead what you could do is you
could make a scenario where the security guard has
an extremely jealous wife who thinks he's cheating
on her and he and she think he's supposed to stay
at his desk and just like let people into the room
he tells her over and over I got to go in there
and unlock both doors no I swear you when all
the pretty girls show up you go inside and you
go in there with him because you want to flirt
and you go in there with one more girl and
I'm Gonna Leave You and I'm gonna sit here
in the lobby and watch and make sure that you
don't now you gotta conflict he's sitting there
going I can't open I can't let you in there
I can't do it or my wife is going to leave me
and and the other character is now getting in
now you have two characters with two separate
goals that are slamming into each other this is
very very it sounds so simple to do but this is
where it's important to like really outline and
put on a I like putting on a big white board
your directions that your characters are going
and make them go into each other and then more
importantly attach Stakes to each one of them if
I don't get into that safe deposit box to get the
whatever marriage certificate if I
don't get that I can't prove that I was
I'll lose my inheritance if I can't show that
I whatever okay now you have steaks and then
you put the security guard where his marriage
is going to fall apart if he lets you in great
you can almost feel the tension go up you can
feel it on set too when you have a scene that
has these kinds of things attached to it the
actors relish it like they can immediately you
feel it come alive you can feel it right how you
can just suddenly the tension goes up you haven't
even started working on escalations and how you
you suddenly amp up the tension in a scene like
that or adding and Ticking it's 459 and it closes
at five we haven't even gotten there yet it's just
two characters with goals now it gets a lot
easier to to really make a scene work that's
where it always begins that's that's the initial
building box did you see come back to the five
and dime Jimmy Dean Robert Altman it's based on a
play it's from 1982 or something so it's just one
room it's a Woolworth in like Marfa Texas and all
the characters it's all women except for one man
and he's in and out it's kind of a memory and the
just the subtleties that it's not on the nose but
you learn about the characters then you learn
about their Petty gripes and jealousies with
one another you learn about the small town gossip
all of it is slowly revealed until the real story
finally comes out but it it's so excellent and
you're just there riveted and it's one location
yeah writing scenes in one location is especially
simple ones with just character driven with no
fancy tricks it is the most challenging thing
but I do believe that that's where all scenes
should begin no matter if they're in space or some
sci-fi time travel epic or not because that's a
foundation right now if you never go into outer
space or back in time and you stay in the room
with the Woolworths you don't have any way to
wave your hands around to distract the audience
that you have nothing does that make sense like
so I think that if you really want to create
more complex sci-fi stories you need to really
get good really good at writing those simple
start writing scenes with two characters
each of them has something that they want
only one of them can win both of
them can lose write a scene like
that that's a page Turner and you're going to
be amazing at riding the Big Space Opera like
it's hard to do but it's that's so if you want
to make it as a screenwriter that's you have to
master that how hard is it to write an emotional
scene for me personally well I should say for me
personally it's not as hard and I only say that
because I tend to be very intuitive in my writing
process and a lot of times when I'm writing
I'm feeling it a lot more than other people are
that as an intuitive kind of person
I just have very deep emotions and
they just come out really easily and
there's very easy to spill it on the page
but the challenge for me is actually
getting the audience to feel the same way
so on I'm about to say unfortunately
it comes down to structure it's really
if you really want to pull out
emotion it's it has less to do with
depth as it has to do with the structure of
your scene because the structures what's gonna
the structure is your frame of your house but
the emotion is the furniture within it so without
that structure of the house you're just gonna
have furniture sitting in the middle of a field
it's just gonna feel weird it's gonna even if the
actor's bringing it it's still going to be kind of
in this weird nebulous space it's not really
much of anything but with the structure it's
what contains everything it's super vital it get
back gets back to the same kind of stuff we were
just talking about about the importance of goals
and stakes and all kinds of things like that like
if you wanna I could I could very easily
write out an emotional scene about someone
who lost their father like you could have
someone oh I miss dad and he passed away
and if you just tuned in and watched the one scene
and the actress does a great performance pulling
that out yeah it might be compelling but it's
not going to have the impact that you that you
want it to have unless you understand more about
why dad's loss was so important right where what
that relationship was like that's all that's all
the structure of backstory and context that you
need to set up so that when we get to emotional
scene it it's paying off in the way that you mean
for it to otherwise it's just one character
spouting off and just kind of being emotional
Denzel Washington could pull that
off but even then if it doesn't have
forward direction to it it's just not gonna
land the way you hope and this happens a lot
as in my personal Journey as a screenwriter
where I'm just like so feeling these scenes
that I've written and then other people read
and go yeah this wasn't quite planning ah it's
so yeah what the guy's pouring his heart
out on paper yeah it's because there's
the guy's all he's doing is pouring his hot art on
paper without going anywhere he's just wallowing
and there's no point there's no direction
there's there's do it's so much more in the
movie Breaking Bad or a movie the pilot episode
of Breaking Bad there's a fantastic scene in there
where Walter White if you've seen this show he
he starts off as this very vanilla spineless guy
and you watch him take this journey where you
learn that he's got cancer he's gonna die he
realizes his life is over he realizes he's got
no savings to save his family and then through
all this he's realizing he's a chemistry teacher
and he knows about science and all this stuff
and he sees that criminals who sell math make a
lot of money and he sees oh there's a way for me
to make a lot of money right so he's watching his
journey going through all these steps and there's
this great scene right after he's bought all the
equipment he's decided he's going to cook meth
and he's this very introverted character and Jesse
comes up to him and says this isn't how I remember
you at all like like at all like you you were this
kind of douche like the just this lame teacher
that just didn't seem like he cared about anything
and all of a sudden you just have this passion
what is it what happened and I think the
performance of the scene was very powerful Walter
White looks at him he says I'm awake it's so
simple but it carries so much of a punch because
you had all of this really good setup framework
of his life and you watch how his life is like
teak things are falling apart he's dying he's not
going to leave anything in this world and you see
him wake up and it carries the emotional impact
because we saw it we experienced it all with him
and then boom you're hit with it around that scene
I I that's what makes emotional scenes work now
is it easy to do I don't think it's easy to do
I think it takes a lot of practice and hard work
but now if someone else could do all that work
for me and set all that up and then write in the
emotional scene by itself it's super easy for me
because I think that way but yeah the challenge
is is all the context so an emotional scene
where you're just like bleeding in front of the
audience doesn't work unless there's a setup
I mean it could work I just don't think it's
it's not going to carry the same punch that you
want it to unless they know why they're feeling
this way why this is such a big moment if I mean
and think of it like if if there is a character
that you're following in a movie or show and all
they do is that they're constantly emotional it's
just a late it's a chore to watch you don't
want to see it it's too much have you ever
seen a movie that's just so sad and such a drag
that you don't actually want to watch it again
that's the kind of feeling you're gonna get you
kind of need the journey you need the setup you
need the context you need the goal the stakes
and all that to so that once that character
does get to that emotional break you're in your
you want you're on the journey right with them
so yes it could be powerful on its own and those
are the odd the clips we see from the Oscars
the best first nominee for Academy Award is
Jared Leto and you see the emotional scene
that's fine for a minute but it's not going
to carry the punch unless you see the hole
thing I don't think did you watch the Queen's
Gambit yeah excellent did you like it yes very
much and this what I've took from that is that
her her circumstances were showing us this build
up but did she really have any full did she ever
feel sorry for herself I felt like she didn't and
she just turned it all into the chess matches
that's where she took any type of self-pity or
whatever was beating whoever it was that she
wanted to be that's a good point that's a good
point it's I actually think it's hard to watch
shows where characters feel sorry for themselves
it's they're out there I can't think of one
an example top my head but I think it's hard
ER to watch you want to see a character take
their terrible background and turn it into
something make it their power that's what that's
exciting to watch like the Queen's Gambit this
little girl raised an orphan suddenly becomes
a chess genius oh I'm him like that's awesome
like because she she's the it's a classic Underdog
Story sure if if Rocky all did nothing but whine
about his poor background and how he never
got a chance as a boxer and that's the end
it would be hard to watch but he he goes the
distance with Apollo Creed and we're like yeah
so yeah what was one of the
first films to make you cry oh
you know I asked what the first film that
made me cry I tell you the one that had the
biggest impact on me this is such a weird one
but it was The Prince of Tides I don't know
if you've ever seen that film but it is a gut
wrencher I'm sure that I got emotional in films
prior to that but that one for some reason really
stands out because it deals with the sky kind of
coming to terms with his very very tragic past
and I will say that for me emotions were always
very much a struggle because they I always
looked at them as something that was weak
which is a problem for a director and someone
who tells stories in my household growing
up showing the showing of vulnerability and
emotion was dangerous it's just not something
that you could do and at and I do remember as
I watched films getting pulled in emotionally
whether it was sadness tears or Terror
those two deep vulnerability things
were stuff that I tried not to show and tried
very hard to fight it's part of what made me a
filmmaker because when I would feel terrified
or really sad I would pull myself out and look
at the way the film was constructed started
looking at oh let me oh it's just an actor
sitting there and there's a director talking to
them and oh look at the interesting lighting I
would purposely start to deconstruct the film
to pull myself out of the entire experience
it took me many many years to really become
comfortable with just my own emotions
I don't know why Prince of Tides stands
if you've ever seen that film it's a fairy
it's Barbra Streisand and Nick Nolte and he's
this kind of big man and he's he ends up like
just sobbing and breaking down that film really
hit me hard because I think it was very similar
to my own life that's probably why it stands
out to me so much it's one that just boom but
emotions are very key to the the business that
we're in and I think it's really important to
be comfortable with that especially as a director
because I need to be I'm asking actors to do that
and I want to be pulled in by that right I'm
asking audiences to be pulled in by those same
emotions well then what am I doing trying to fight
it all the time and act like I don't feel anything
I maybe I'm in the wrong business if
that's how I'm approaching all of this
learning how to be okay with expressing emotions
I mean it's taken me a long time but I've gotten
to a point now where I can be on set talking
to an actor and they're just dumping out how
they feel and it's very they're in this very
broken place we're trying to capture that
and I am with them because I want to show
them it's okay so I oftentimes will be
crying with them so sometimes that will
happen but I'm also trying to talk to my DP
and the Wardrobe person in between all of this
so I have to be comfortable enough while I'm in
this kind of broken spot with them to turn to my
DP while I'm all right so let's grab the 85 and
then when we go on this moment but like not be for
years and years and years I struggled with that
position of like ah they're gonna think I'm ugh
what a wuss I had to like really learn to let that
go it helps the entire room when you can embrace
it and just be okay with it it will I feel like it
will be imprinted on the DNA of the film if you're
okay with it it'll help pull the audience in too
some people are much easier with that than others
I I struggle with it for many many years but
yeah so Prince of time it's a tough watch
okay I'll have to go back and look at that
so it's an obscure one it's funny that that's
the one that pops into my mind is the first
but yeah I remember watching that one it's
like oh it's it's a good movie directed by
Barbra Streisand and she's in it with Nick
Nolte yeah wow yeah how many movies can
you name off the top of your head that if
you saw them today they would make you cry
oh boy okay off the top of my head
it's gonna sound so funny Jaws and I tell
you why Jaws in the scene when the little
boy is mimicking his dad what I'm talking
about where he's he's having a tough day and
and he's just sitting there thinking and the
other boys at the table and he's like imitating
his father and he he realizes his son is copying
him and they're going back and forth doing all
these it's just it's just a beautiful moment and
in the end Roy Scheider leans over to the boy and
says give me a kiss and the kid goes why because
because I need it ah that scene gets me every time
and I think it's that definitely like father-son
scenes like the second Guardians of the Galaxy
movie when he wasn't he may have been
your daddy but he may have been your
father but he wasn't your daddy yandu no oh I'm
just a mess anything that deals with Father and
Son coming together and having this body usually
really gets me I who off the top of my head um
oh man I'm gonna think of it like as soon as
the camera stops and be like oh this one and
this one and this one and this one I just
watched coded that one got me that was if
you're familiar with it it stands for children
of deaf adults and it's about a deaf family
and the daughter is can hear the rest of the
family cannot and she wants to do music It's
A Beautiful film Beautiful film Emily gets
me quite a bit it's just this beautiful
love story about her finding love and it's
just so it's just such a wonderful film um
I'm sure I'll be able to think more later
but yeah yeah and I get more comfortable
with it as I get older of just like being
vulnerable to a lot of that stuff but yeah
does a director automatically deserve respect
no
I mean I think that the director automatically
wants respect but they don't necessarily deserve
it I think and when you see frustration
from directors is because they don't have
any respect and people are just walking all over
him that usually comes from a director that is
not prepared or not not prepared and just not
doing the job that they're supposed to be doing
it they they need respect they should have
respect because you're in charge of some
usually something larger even if it's a smaller
production you still got some money on the line
but they it you've got you're you're the
person in the position of a pile of money
you have a Target that you're aiming for at the
end of it with some sort of story or something
you have to dictate things to all these other
departments and if they don't have your respect
they are not going to be delivering their best
work more than likely because if they don't like
you if they're if they don't respect you or don't
want to be there they're going to probably just
try to they're just trying to power through the
day that's a really bad that you don't want your
team members in that position and I don't think
that that if you find yourself in that position
it's this is not necessarily because you have
experience or not that's not usually doesn't have
anything to do with it it's usually
it has to do with your preparation
directors who are not prepared really lose
the respect of their crew very quickly because
the worst possible thing you can do on set as a
director is not know what you want to sit there
the clock is ticking and you're going should we
put we should put the camera so if we put the
camera up here and then ah it makes everyone crazy
and they're going to start rolling their eyes and
being very frustrated with you and they're gonna
start in second guessing your decisions and things
like that coming into your location beforehand
and knowing they're going to enter through this
door and they're going to go out to that door and
I I want to just move the camera this way you have
to know every little detail but having an idea of
what you want it's super important and you could
do that with that experience and if you don't know
how to to even shoot a scene you can get your DP
to help you with that as long as what you want
that comes from preparation even having like an
idea of say for example a wardrobe you want I want
it to look like this guy has been up all night
that can be enough of a description for your
wardrobe person at least now they know what
you want okay so he's he slept in his clothes okay
good and so a little bit of wrinkles in yeah yeah
that kind of thing if you came in and you're like
I don't know he's just wearing like clothes like
normal but that's maddening to work for You're
Gonna Lose the respect of everybody really quickly
so it's absolutely vital to have respect but it's
not something that you will get just automatically
but you can get it by make sure you're doing
the work so shot listing and storyboarding yep
shot listing storyboarding is very helpful you
don't have to storyboard necessarily there's a
lot of schools of thought on that it depends
on the style that you're going for sometimes
you don't have time so like there's a show
I've been working on where we're running so
fast there's not time for storyboards there's
not even time for a shot list but at least
knowing the basics even like I'm prepared as
much as I can be in the moment I know that these
two characters are coming in and this is their
objective and we have to get them back out and we
have to do it in five minutes or less so at least
having some goal posts to hit at a minimum is
helpful the more the better it is and the easier
it is for your team to work with you what's your
image of a Bad director Badger I've seen a lot
of bad directors I can picture them in my mind
that the first believe it or not the first sign I
see of a Bad director is someone who doesn't know
how to talk to an actor I I think think about
what it takes to be a director you can do it
the best place for a director to be is like
television you can go into a television and
the DP already is set to look the this
the writers wrote everything for you
the actors know their characters and
you don't really have to do anything but
the the the DP is probably going to be able
to set it up and while we normally shoot it
when the guy goes over here and he cooks dinner
there this is normally how we shoot the scene
okay great the actors are still going to know
what you want so if you don't know how to talk
to them and they're and they're feeling alone
and vulnerable that that's that's a problem um
and that is the one job that
no one can really help you with
someone else can light it someone else can get
all the costumes ready in the stunts and stuff but
someone's got to talk to the actors someone's
going to give them emotions and and help pull
moments out of them especially if they've shut
down who else is going to do that for you you it's
up to you so there's no more important job than
that I think how do you gut check yourself to know
hey am I moving into Bad director mode yeah if I
feel like I'm in danger of being a bad director
I'm just I'm waiting for all the commas to appear
below the video like you are a bad director
if I feel like I'm I'm edging into that
territory it always comes down to my prep
if I find myself department heads are asking me
so what do you want for the color of the
walls and I haven't thought about that yet
I know that especially if we're approaching
the shoot I know that there's a problem and
especially if there are gaps like what I've
noticed is is what I was called bad directing
it's really easy to focus just
on one aspect of the shoot like
oh it's going to be in place all lit with
Christmas lights and and it's going to be
shot on a Steadicam and we're going to spin in a
circle cool so what are the actors doing oh we'll
figure that out when we get there you haven't
really thought about that department too much
that's that's that's usually my gut going alarm
Bells alarm Bells you you need to take a minute
and sit and think about that this comes back
to a big thing I think we all struggle with
which is resistance your gut you inside
know what you need to do to be successful
but sometimes for whatever reason Boop it
comes up where you you just don't want to
you'll resist sitting down and writing out
your shot list because it feels a lot like work
so I know that if I if there are there's usually
that thing and sometimes it's shotless and I like
doing shot lists that's what's so crazy but
if I feel like I haven't done it or see that
I haven't done it and my alarm bells are going off
inside I'm definitely leaning into bad territory
and I feel it on set because there's always this
little sense of inner Panic that comes up where
I don't know what I'm what I'm doing here
it's it is a really uncomfortable bad spot
to be in when it happens because it's
already hard enough on set it's already
and where else it comes up is where I
think that I don't need to think about it
whenever I approach a situation where oh it's just
another breakup scene we shot a bunch of these
it's just gonna be in the ice cream shop the two
things they're going to leave and I don't put the
work in because I don't feel like I really need
to that's usually when things really go south too
oh the ice cream shop is closed and they and
the actor is allergic to Dairy oh oh well I
don't know what to do that because that kind of
thing will happen it just happens all the time so
which is why you prepare which is why you
do the work ahead of time you're preparing
for Murphy because Murphy will show up he will
make no mistake about it that's why you prepare
because everything is going to go sideways
on you at some point it just will so yeah
you've brought up persistence a lot are you a fan
of the war of Art yes the war yes because that's
how it starts right it talks about resistance
that that really rung my bell when he talked about
that like because you the thing about resistance
that's so Sinister is that no one else can tell
you we can we're really good at making ourselves
look busy even to our partners or on social media
but we know if we're resisting we're the only ones
who know generally if you're supposed if that you
have that screenplay that you're supposed to
be writing and you just aren't no one's your
partner may be looking you'd be oh he works on
it every day but is he though am I though we We
Only We Know It And so it's yeah it and it can
look like all sorts of things it can look like
it can look like exercise every time I sit down
to write that oh I just need to go for a walk
oh guess what you're not doing while you're
walking you're not writing it could look like
I think he even says in the book it could
be sex could be a resistance thing you just
suddenly I'm really horny
yeah for every person is different social media is
probably the biggest resistance blocker which is
and social media is a killer for art it's
killer it doesn't favors whatsoever it's
there really isn't any purpose to it
especially for artists like what are
you doing if like what do we really need it
for how is it actually helping your career
we like to we like to kid ourselves and tell us
that oh well people need to know that I'm busy
do they though like how many jobs have
we legitimately gotten from Facebook
I mean unless you're in part of a Facebook
group that posts a job and you happen
to be one of the first five that do it and
they're looking for an art Department person
I I can't think of it I people will message
me and say it looks like you're busy but I've
never landed a job from one of those social media
platforms it's all about the grand advertisement
to show people that you're more important than you
are that's usually the point of social media is
yeah not the point of everything to advertise
to the world that you're more successful more
good looking more that your life is so great and
perfect probably isn't that what we do as humans
yeah we just want to fool everyone into thinking
that we're something yeah for any new filmmakers
watching can you take us through the process of
making a film all the way from getting financing
to getting cast attached below the line people
working all yeah if we're talking about making
a specif like a movie specifically that's what you
mean like actually yeah so the general process of
making the movie is of course it starts with
a script got to get a script from somewhere
hopefully fine financing in some way shape or
form but whether that's an investor or credit
cards or something usually at that point then
you find casting then it becomes putting your
crew together probably starting with someone like
a cinematographer deciding to look the props you
move into production you're doing that whole scene
and then then it's post on the end of it that's
the general building blocks which are probably
fairly obvious the trick is how do you do it how
do you if you're if you've never done it like how
do you even move that ball down the field at all
that's usually the big question how do I make
a movie how do you get on the world do you do
it I've done three features to this point and
each one of them came about in different ways
the first one so actually the first one I
ever tried to make I I did everything you
were supposed to do I read all the books
I read Rebel Without a crew I did I read
all the books that all the filmmakers
read about independent film and whatever
I wrote a script my mom told me it was really
great and all my friends told me how great it was
I found an investor a guy who helped me with a
business plan but he was only willing to invest
in the trailer he didn't have enough money
to actually fund the whole film but he knew
business cool that's something I lack so we
wrote it we did a killer trailer we set out
to raise money everybody told me you have never
made a feature so how and I was trying to raise
like a million bucks I think I was sorry budget
every investor said this is a high-risk investment
and you've never made a movie so how am I how do
I know I'm ever going to see it again and how do
I know what you're doing I heard that over and
over and over again for several years before I
finally gave up it was so demoralizing because
actually the trailer we made was good we thought
for sure people would be into it didn't work
didn't work at all it was not what the books
told me that would happen it was not it was
very frustrating so here I am Back Square One
got this cool movie trailer yay for a film that
doesn't exist okay so I had to go back to the
drawing board and go all right so then how do I
make a movie how do I get this thing made so I I
wrote a different script and I wrote this script
based on things that I knew I had access to so
I shoot a lot of underwater stuff all right I can
I can maybe add some of that I wouldn't recommend
that and it's an independent feature film I did
it anyway wrote this little murder mystery thing
I set out to raise forty thousand dollars forty
thousand I was thinking before I thought to myself
I've shot a lot on my camera I've shot I have
a lot of experience behind the camera I had
tried to teach myself as much as I could about
filmmaking I'd worked with another director a
whole bunch and he showed me how 5c stands and a
couple of flags and a little light kit can really
do a lot for you so I'm like and I learned a lot
from him he taught me all this great stuff so I
bought I literally bought five C stands handful of
flags had a light kit that's it that's all I had
doorway Dolly little bit of track and okay I can
I can make a movie with just these few elements
I'll cast my friends as the actors I'm gonna raise
40 Grand I couldn't raise 40 Grand I raised 12.
and all the people that threw in was fantastic
they were all good friends of mine but that
still left me in this place of like man how am
I supposed to pull this off without anything
I decided Well I'm gonna take
that money and use it for catering
and for the couple of rentals that
I need and I'm gonna do it anyway
so I sat out and shot for five straight weeks
I shot it during this is this is really helpful
the people I cast the first one was an actor who
was in acting school he was on his Christmas break
for a month so he was actually home for a month
that I could grab him for that was very helpful
I did not break the shoot up into tiny pieces
like a lot of people do because that gets really
dangerous because your actors someone's gonna
get married that someone's going to get a haircut
trying to coordinate people for months and months
and months on end it's increasingly difficult to
do so I tried to shoot it all in one block just
to get it knocked out and get it out of the way
so over at Christmas time was a great
time work is slow gear is available
sometimes Crews available that made everything
exponentially easier I paid everybody with food
had a friend do the K we we came up with this
little and by the way everything we had a crew
of five every all the lighting fit in my SUV
and the I had this little tupperware container
with napkins forks and knives salt and pepper
things like that that the K this friend of mine
was kind of helping us cater and she would fill
that up and had all the crafty in it I could just
pull it out and wheel it it didn't set and she
would bring like a casserole or something every
morning it was a great little system she wasn't
there all day but it was something so that the
crew was taken care of and I planned like I've
never planned before like I I went and looked
at each location I measured each room to make
sure that the because I wanted to know if I
want to do a doorway Dolly shot through this
little doorway is it even wide enough for me
to do that so I measured it to make sure it was
right and then pre-planned out where all my shots
would be so that I could be a military operation
in every single location because I did not have
the money to to be able to do extra reshoots and
things like that so I had this giant three ring
binder like this that with every little detail at
every scene which scene came before which scene
came after so that I could meet because I didn't
have a scripty I had myself I was DP I had three
film students and I had a art Department person
and a stunt coordinator like those were that
was it that's all I had so I needed to be able to
create a system to where I could do it all myself
and I did it I pulled it off now I will say it was
one of the most exhausting experiences of my life
it I actually put myself in the hospital from
exhaustion I've ended up passing out in the shower
but I did it I got it done and sometimes
making your first feature will take that
to you'll have you may hopefully not you may have
to push yourself further than you ever thought
possible but if you want it this might be what you
have to do push yourself so much further than you
thought and it wasn't like I had this great day
job gig where I could afford to take all this time
off I couldn't I was living on credit cards and I
had to push and push and push now here's the thing
foreign that film it's you can watch it if you
want it's a 12 000 movie it's never gonna be
it it's a talk it looks like a n sounds like
a twelve thousand dollar movie and it's not
anything great you can it's on Amazon it's called
the human Trace you can watch it if you want
watch it only to inspire
you to make something better
I would also tell you at the same time go watch
Christopher Nolan's following it was shot for
like six grand so but because Christopher
Nolan made following he got to make Memento
right sometimes it takes that first one to get
you out the door and if no one is giving you a
shot you're just gonna have to figure out how
to give it to yourself that's what I had to do
and it took everything I had to make it happen
but I will tell you that after 25 years later
it is my most proudest accomplishment because
I did it on my own and I did it and I made it
happen you won a couple awards did okay it was
never sold for a lot of money it didn't do you're
we're all hoping we're all hoping that when we do
it that that's going to be the thing that opens
the door don't count on that it probably won't
hey if it happens for you that's fantastic but
be careful what how you pin your hopes on on that
one project and I learned that in the biggest way
on film number two so so film number one was
done the true Indie filmmaker way which was
she Blood Sweat and Tears doing everything
yourself all of that even to the point we
recorded like all the underwater Sounds by taking
a microphone and putting a condom around it and
dipping it in a swimming pool and then making
underwater sounds and did all the sound design
like that like it was it was interesting safe
recording that that's right no one got pregnant
uh so that's one way that you can do it and I will
say that the process of that now the film itself
did not open doors however from that point forward
I could tell people that I made a movie they're
not going to watch this movie that doesn't matter
I could tell people that I made the movie that
did help when it came to the second one because
I was able to tell people I've done this before
I've been through this Mill before I know how to
make a two-hour story and make it hold together
second film was done was paid for by a large
organization that they wanted to dramatize a book
so this is an interesting now this is another way
you can make films happen and I've seen people do
this because they will take a story and wrap it
around a Cause if you can attach your story to
say a book like in the case of this it was a book
they wanted to dramatize or you can come up with a
cause say I don't know voting rights or ending
childhood hunger or something right there are
organizations that really they're champions of
this and massive organizations that are around
it fight this kind of thing and you can get them
to partner with you you will also have a built-in
audience it's a great way to get a film going if
if your film has some sort of bent like that it'll
give you a platform access to investors and things
like that cool that's fantastic it also it feels
good when you get out of bed in the morning
because you're making a film that's actually
doing good like this so my next film was like
that what that means is that means two things
I'm working for a client that's
different than your own little film
this is going to be more like what it was like
working in a studio and I'm also making a film
based on pre-existing materials so I'm adapting
a book for a client so that means that I have
to work with a committee of people who are
dictating the story and they're telling me
things they want in it certain agendas that
they have that is a that is what you will run
into when you do a film for an organization
this is it's not necessarily A Bad Thing it
can be a very collaborative feeling in this case
it was a very positive creative experience the
the executive producer and myself are very good
friends to this day we're still working together
we made this film it's called The Record
Keeper it it was a wonderful experience to
make it's a steampunk sci-fi thriller about
angels and all that it was super super fun
but the organization decided at the end of it
not to release it and it's a whole long sort
of story as to why but this taught me lesson
number two which is when you tie your hopes
to what your project can do or will do
it's a dangerous place to be it's it's some people
refer to that as living in the future you are
I I wish I could remember which sports team this
was but I know there's a famous story about a
football team that was it was playing this game
and this one team thought they had won it and
I think there was a interception or a tackle or
something and team a Ah that's it we won the game
and the fans started flooding the the stadium
and things like that but the play wasn't over
and the other team somehow grabbed the ball
picked up and run it to the other end zone
and it was discovered somehow in this
crazy celebration that they actually lost
viewers may remember what this story is I can't
quite remember what it is off the top of my head
but that this is actually something to happen this
is an example of a team that got so focused on
the future of winning X going to film festival
winning winning Sundance that they completely lost
sight of where they actually were and that was a
very devastating lesson for me to learn which was
we made this film we were winning Awards people
were so excited we were on set you could feel the
Magic in the air as we were creating and we're
working with actors the story was really cool
we felt like we were on this launching pad
and all of a sudden we go launching into the
stratosphere and the organization says no and I
took a tumble off of that into a very dark place
to the point where I almost gave up making films
it was so hard because you we worked so hard to
get through you to break through right you're
just trying every step of the way to write the
screenplays to work with the actors and then
finally someone gives you a shot and then they
bam they shut the door on your face it felt like
well then what's the point it just it I seriously
thought about my wife and I talked at length
about maybe we should just go teach English
in Korea or something and just give up it was
because I was pinning my hopes on what it I
thought it was going to do up here and I lost
sight of where the reality of where it actually
was realizing this is a very real possibility
the signs were there going along that this could
happen but I just didn't want to see it I just
believed that it would do better than that so
I recovered from that whole experience which took
some time took a lot of licking of the wounds and
eventually down the line I got back on my feet I
ended up at this for a time I worked I did I ended
up getting a job it was a way that I I got to LA
and this is something very interesting because
I feel like the second film that I did if I
had lived in La things would have turned out
differently because my friend's Circle would have
been different well I was living in another city
and the people that I was surrounded by and
people making movies the artists involved
were just from that City if I had been in La
making this with LA people I think other it would
have been higher exposure I think the results
would have been different that's as a side note
so after all this went down it was also
financially devastating so I had to find
a way to get to La after all of this after
this huge wound and and all right now I need
I need to get down there and try to figure
out a way to make this happen so I ended up
taking a full-time job which was very that after
going whoop I want to be I want to be famous ah
work a full-time job at a job I hate I'm the
world's worst person right so boom so I'm in
this full-time job but but while I was in this
job first of all I gave myself a time limit
I'm not I'm only going to be here for a year
this is just to get me to La so I I did that
and while I was in the job I thought okay I need
to get film number three off the ground I can't
let this second experience be the death of me I
can't let that be the defining moment of my life
so I went to the Austin film festival and I
met Dwayne Worrell there and we connected and
I followed up with him this is the traditional
way how movies are supposed to be made right so
we get back to LA we became Fast Friends he sends
me the script I couldn't put it down I love the
script so much I asked him if it was okay if I
pitched it around he said yes I went to another
Film Festival connected with these other group
of producers came back they said to them they
said that's great that's a green line now this is
the traditional way of how you want it to happen
in Hollywood right so these are three different
possible ways of how films get made is any of
them right or wrong absolutely not but it's just a
way of demonstrating and how this actually happens
the third way I will say is has been the
most interesting because I'm working for
a production house who's done multiple
films there's a great comfort in that
because they have had things distributed way more
than I have they have done they they understand
the ins and outs of the other side of the business
that I'm not as familiar with that's fantastic
there's also a great because I'm in La I have a
great network of filmmakers to choose from to help
me make this thing that's also a huge asset it's
given us access to film festivals that I didn't
have before so there's enormous value in going
after a film like that in that way now the film is
about to release at the time of this recording so
we will see how this particular process goes but I
so how is a film made it's it's in any way
that you possibly can it's you you I had
to put myself in the hospital make the first
one I had to take a job I hated for the Third
and all of them were worth it because once you're
there and you're doing it it is the the dream that
we've all striven for it's real It's Magic it's
it's fantastic it's the best job in the world.